how do you become a professional
director if no one will give you a
chance
no ah that's such a good question and I
think that's the question that everyone
asks every day like how how in the world
do you do it
you know
I just two nights ago I was just having
dinner with two filmmaking friends one
was a producer director the other was a
director we asked ourselves the exact
same question the maddening question of
how in the world do you
get in break in get work
I do think that there are ways to do it
but the first thing I think there's
multiple steps and the first step is to
understand that there is no way there is
no
path you know if you want to be a doctor
if you want to be a lawyer there is a
set ABCD to do it right you know you go
to school for x amount of years you get
your residency you do your entry you
they have mapped it out for you that's
not like that in film
and I'm often asked how do you
well how did you do it well
or someone will say should I go do the
DGA program and like go up that route
sure that there is that way of doing it
you can go do there are certain you know
courses that they'll have lined out like
different networks will do it like
Warner Brothers might have their little
internal program and you can go in and
study under somebody and work your way
up if that works great that is a way
yeah should you make an indie film
yes sure if you can do it and pull that
off and
that is a way like but it's not a
guaranteed wait that's super important
to understand there's I I heard a
screenwriter describe it once as it's
like we're all Blind Men with our hands
against a wall trying to find a way into
the Magic Kingdom and we're all feeling
our way along and one of us will oh
we'll find a crack and we'll slip
through but the problem is the crack
closes behind us so we can't turn around
and tell anyone behind us or get in that
way now that that was the yours specific
weird path in getting in and that's it
so I think
how do you get in I think the first step
is
um understanding that there really isn't
a set path it's just however you can get
to point B
do that
that's so vague I know that's vague I'm
aware and it's maddening
um
I think there's a second important step
to this I would say that
do not
the Trap that I fall into and a lot of
us filmmakers fall into is the
well how did John get that job that
thing it's
John has I've been on sets where I'm
watching a director work and I'm like
how in the world did this person land
that like they have no idea what they're
doing the minute your brain starts to go
down that path especially when you're
around your artist friends
and you all start to spiral in this how
in the why in the world is so and so
working and I'm not it is a maddening
exercise it is a
exercise and frustration and there is no
joy at the end of it and you will never
find an answer because it doesn't make
sense you know
um I think it's very important to watch
your mental attitude when it comes to
that kind of thing and the reason why is
because if you start thinking about that
kind of thing all the time
you are going to start to project a
negative kind of energy
you know and that's the kind of thing
people pick up on you know if you're
interviewing for that gig
and you're feeling extremely frustrated
that no one's brought you on
it you may not even talk about it but
it's going to be there if you've allowed
your mind to circle around that drain so
I would say immediately you got to turn
that off and stop trying to
make sense out of this madness
more practical steps though I think
that the first thing
is you have to generate
a lot of work
that now that's going to sound like
what do you mean I thought the answer
I'm asking you how do I get into this
place where I'm generating a lot of work
yes in order to generate a lot of work
you kind of have to already do it on
your own
but that doesn't mean movies that
doesn't mean you have to be making
movies or television shows because
little secret
my real that you can look at
the vast majority of the things on that
reel are not movies or television shows
they are other side projects other
little things that look cinematic
they're just not part of any kind of
project that you will ever see
um
and there's really cool ways to do that
uh and I had a
really big Epiphany and I know the last
time I was interviewed here I talked
about this where
I had been trying to be a filmmaker for
a hundred years you know I was just
struggling and just and I found that I
was angry all the time I just I was so
I was shooting a lot of live corporate
events where I'm just literally the
camera guy in the middle of the Arena
like panning left and panning right by
some speaker
walking back and forth on the stage
giving the annual report on you know
boring corporate I'm wearing a suit and
tie I am so far away from being on set
where it's exciting and there's
explosions and all of this
I am just twisted and angry and
it was not a life it was not an
existence
that I would ever want to go back to and
I realized one day
as I was in the middle of making a
training film for I think it was for
like a shipping company like how to like
you know package something it was like
as dry as it gets
and then I watched the movie Jurassic
Park
and in Jurassic Park you know that movie
came out when it was late 90s is that
safe to say somewhere early 2000s late
90s somewhere
it's over 20 years old right
there's a scene in that movie about how
dinosaurs are made remember this scene
Mr DNA the little DNA cartoon comes out
and it's explaining to the audience how
dinosaurs were made and the characters
in this in the movie are all sitting in
their little seats and it's like a
little roller coaster ride I don't know
if you remember that scene but they're
all asking questions to the animated
thing and the uh the host of the park is
talking to the cartoon well
um
65 million years ago a mosquito would
land on a dinosaur and suck out some of
the blood and that's mosquito would get
trapped in the sap of a tree well that
sap is now called Amber what that is is
a corporate training film directed by
Steven Spielberg
here's the amazing thing about that
scene that film is like 20 some years
old and it's a scene that most people
remember
it's stuck in their mind you get the
things what it stands out to you from
Jurassic Park well when the T-Rex breaks
through the gate and the whole
Velociraptor chasing them oh yeah and Mr
DNA
that one stands out
and at the moment when I was watching it
back then I was like
I wonder if Steven Spielberg was all
pissed off and and angry when he had to
direct this part of his movie
I pretty sure he wasn't I think
Spielberg went
okay I have to find a way to communicate
boring
material to my audience any superhero
movie has to do the same exercise by the
way any any sci-fi fantasy you have to
do the same thing you have to explain
the tech or the superpower to the
audience in an entertaining way it's no
different than
I have to talk about harassment in the
workplace video that I have to I mean
these are the same these are the working
professionals have to do this kind of
stuff and I realized that
well what if I in my training film just
to pretended that it was part of a
larger narrative what if
it just so happens in my little film
about how to make
properly how to properly package a
shipping container
what if I made that and pretended it was
part of Jurassic Park
how would I approach that differently if
it was
it was an internal switch
but at that moment everything changed
because when I would show up to shoot it
I wasn't just going
oh just throw the light over there and
you know I mean we just got to just pan
and scan the boxes no it became
can I make this box look cool it's a box
you know how can I like maybe if I
brought a little Dana dolly or
do a little swooping camera move with
some sound effects and like
you know you you just all of a sudden
you're directing a scene that's direct
and it became it changed the look of my
little tiny corporate films it changed
how and the clients started to see this
excitement when I would come
to shoot their product because how cool
is it for them that someone is actually
thrilled to be there shooting the most
boring dry stuff you can imagine it
changed everything for me that one
decision started to open the door to
other projects just like it and
eventually and even today
I now have a niche where I create
narrative films for corporations they're
like little short films but they're big
budget short films that I'm getting to
it's no different than a movie working
with actors writing a script coming up
with Concepts shooting and I got a thing
coming up that's set in 200 A.D with
Roman soldiers like all because
it's a corporate thing it's all because
of that one decision to
I'm going to pretend that everything I'm
doing is part of this fun magical
Cinematic Universe even if it's an
interview with a CEO you know is there a
way I can make this you know how would
Deacons
shoot this CEO talking about how he
started the company
you're it's fun suddenly it becomes fun
and great and and that kind of thing can
immediately start adding a lot of work
to your reel
I know a lot of directors
who have been in the industry for many
many years who well let me rephrase they
want to be directors they fantasize like
myself they grew up and they saw
uh Back to the Future or Jurassic Park
as kids and and went Ah that's what I
want to do I want to create that and now
they're editing for reality television
or shooting wedding videos and not doing
what they dreamed
you have to get experience directing
and if you were to ask yourself
how many hours have you actually spent
directing
like Beyond this is not on set this is
not onset as a PA or editing or even
writing how many hours have you spent
actually directing
how many hours would that actually be
that is so vital because when you get
your shot when someone does open that
door for you you better hit the ground
running and know exactly how to do it
well
it's kind of a maddening thing to think
about right oh I don't have any
experience directing how do I do that
well
you don't always need a camera one of
the things that I tried that really
transformed a lot of what I do is I
wanted to get better at working with
actors so I invited a couple of actors
to my studio
I gave them a scene from a play I had no
cameras and no lights and I just had the
two of them reading the screen scene to
each other
act out the scene and I tried to see if
I could get them to a better more
connected performance that's it
and it's important to say that this was
not a scene I wrote this is just a scene
out of a play that the actors just got
on the spot
reading through it
do the scene together
and it's so awkward and so hard for the
just the actors okay I'm seeing the
awkwardness I'm seeing the fact that
they're trying to read the lines I
remember what to say I'm seeing that
they're not connecting how can I make
them connect how do I do that
it is terrifying it it I would have
massive anxiety before each time I would
have them come over to try it
um
but it changed everything for me because
now because that's directing that's
sitting there in the chair for hours
all right actors
try holding hands and see if that helps
connect you more or
sinking them into their environment
painting pictures for them imagine that
you're having a picnic on a blanket
right now and there's a storm cloud
coming and the rain pellets are just
starting to fall like feel the rain
smell how the ground is feeling and now
action and see what happens this is all
directing and I would say that if you
don't have any hours doing it this is
one way that you can increase the amount
of work that you're doing so it's so
important and you have to can you have
to be very uh Relentless about it
constantly finding like if you find that
you're in this been in this business for
more than
I don't know
six eight years and you've got one short
under your belt
it's you it's time to step it up and
figure out a way to get something else
done
um
another thing that I've done that's
helped me is
um I had a shoot once where it was just
a little corporate thing
the shoot was on a Friday we had a
little grip truck of grip and lighting
stuff in the truck well that couldn't
return the truck until Monday so that
weekend
I took uh
the truck with the camera that I rented
and on Saturday we just went and got a
couple actors and I wanted to experiment
with some intimate like a love story I'd
never tried that before
I've never done like a love scene I
didn't know how to do it even but I got
some actors that I trusted and they
trusted me and we just
tried stuff and just you know I mean
like a two a couple falling in love and
just what how to shoot intimacy you know
and just create this beautiful little
love story we didn't even have audio we
just had visuals
it's on the it's on my reel it's just
like as something that we played with
and tried it's it's putting work out
there that is super important because
when the window comes and it will there
will come a time when someone decides to
give you a shot you gotta have something
to show them you gotta have
some sort of real they have to believe
in you somehow
so
hopefully you're not trying to scramble
the night before to put something
together like
this is how you do it
um
another way to be working
is you have to you have to aggressively
expand your network
now that
people hear that and they think the word
networking and
that is what I mean but that's not
totally what I mean I I think the better
way to phrase it would be making more
friends
um
usually when people think about
expanding their Network they think about
going to a networking event which I
think is one of the worst places
I mean that can be great but it's one of
the hardest places to actually Network
actually
build your network I think one of the
really good place is actually a film
festival
and the key to things like festivals
screenings
things like that is not just meeting
someone at an event it's following up
so
my the feature I just shot
the reason one of the big the first
things that got going as far as it got
got that feature off the ground was me
meeting the screenwriter at the Austin
Film Festival
and the only reason that I ever even got
the screenplay from him
so his name is Dwayne Worrell he was
speaking on a panel so I'm just an
audience member I didn't even have a
project in the festival I was just there
to attend to meet people to do exactly
what I'm talking about to aggressively
expand my friend Network Dwayne spoke on
this panel because he had written uh it
was an award-winning film through Amazon
called the wall uh John Cena's in it
um
Jason Aaron Aaron Taylor-Johnson
guy from kick ass I'm blanking on his
name he's Quicksilver anyway
directed by Doug Lyman who did The
Bourne Identity and Mr Mrs Smith so wow
Dwayne wow he wrote this wow what a guy
so you know I'm super intimidated but I
go up and I
introduce myself and you know we hit it
off okay but I made sure to get his
contact information so that I could
follow up with him later which we did
once we both got back to LA which is one
of the reasons to live in LA because a
lot of people live here anyway
so we went out to dinner and
that was where it was really important
to just be a person not a desperate
you're so great Dwayne I want to work
with you it was just what do we have in
common he likes Sports uh he like you
know
he likes Sci-Fi Action we just kind of
bonded over common interests and we
became good friends and then it was when
we had this connection then he sent me
the script for the abandon
and when I read it it was like wow
that's the best group I've ever read
then I took that script
went to another Film Festival
and I met a couple of producers
from the I did the same thing same exact
thing met them saw that they had made a
couple of films that were lower budget
after the festival was over I followed
up
said hey would you like to go to coffee
sometime we could chat about whatever
can made a connection hung out with the
guy said you know I just came across
this script that I really liked passed
it to him he read it and said let's do
it let's make a project all of that came
about because of just aggressively
making sure I was constantly meeting
people
um
I will put on task lists each week to
meet more industry people usually if
it's by a month like this month I need
to meet three new people make three new
friends uh
and I would say
I don't limit it to has to be a producer
or an agent
um
it could be anybody in the industry
really because you just don't know
who
ironically I I made a friend in a
writing class that I'm in
this is a super nice guy that's really
humble
soft-spoken guy and he
I learned he just moved to LA so I was
like
oh he just moved to L.A he's a director
like me he's right a director guy and
just just seemed like a nice guy and I
kind of felt bad for him like oh you
probably don't know anybody in L.A you
want to grab a coffee sometime yeah sure
so we went out to Coffee me and my wife
and just hung out with him for a bit
like what does your wife do oh you know
she's an actress like oh yeah I think I
said something like trying to make it in
the big time huh
and I'm like well that'd be fun to
hang out with all of you know maybe
going a double date or whatever you know
just being friends just again expanding
the network
being friends making connections growing
the thing I said
you know what we're having a cookout at
my place you want to come over like you
you know you're new to town you probably
don't know anybody come on out meet some
friends it'd be great to have you
he shows up
and his wife
gets out of the car and she is like
very a very known Golden Globe winning
actress and I'm just like
he
he had no idea who his wife like it was
it's hilarious thinking about it but it
all came about because of this
constant push to continue to make more
friends grow the network because that is
how
jobs get made people the jobs that
rarely don't happen because of the
meeting they happen because you're
hanging out at someone's birthday party
and we're like dude you know what I've
got this idea for a comedy horror we
should you want to do it we should do it
like that happens all of the time all
the time that's how you get things made
is by having all these friends if the
only friends that you have are your mom
and just your couple of buddies you went
to film school with you it's going to be
a lot more difficult for you to actually
get past where you are you have to push
beyond that boundary
what about
uh we hear and we see in the comments we
hear from people you know all the time
that you really can't get any meaningful
work unless you're related to someone
I have heard that myself
um
nepotism is a real thing
um especially if you live in a big Hub
City like La New York
um and you're competing against Kevin
Costner's kids you know or whatever
Spielberg's son who wants to whatever
that is the reality that's who you're
dealing with
well
I think it's really easy to fall back on
that excuse and say well I can't because
I'm not anyone's son
I grew up far away from Hollywood now
I'm not directing Marvel films at the
moment but that doesn't mean I'm not
working right so
you it your future and your career is
something you have to grab a hold of we
can make a thousand excuses all day long
about the reasons why we're not making
it if that's what you're doing with your
creative time then that's probably why
you're not making it
yes good for them you know Steven
Spielberg's son I don't even know his
name but good for that guy like he's got
a connection and a good end well
then maybe you should
become friends with someone like that
you know maybe you should
find a way to make invent your own
nepotism you know like become best
friends with a showrunner if you can you
know like that's how
because look to be honest like I would
function the same way we like to like
throw the blame on this oh it's all
politics and it's all who you know yeah
and I do the same thing when I hire a
project
and I need a DP who do you think I'm
going to call do I call
some demo reel that I've seen online of
a DP I've never met or am I going to
call you know Sally who I know isn't
awesome and she's super talented and
we've worked that's who I'm a call
because that's how we're all like that
right we all want to work with our
friends and we all want to have this
solid team of people
so it goes back to just
making sure that you are connected to
the right people I mean that's really it
sounds simple but that's really and
rather than um making excuses as to oh
I'm not connected anyone I'm not
so-and-so's relative
I think that's just an excuse to not go
out and actually do the scary work of
becoming friends with you know these
people
my personal humble opinion
but so when you've been to networking
events
it's it's kind of reminds me of like you
know these like singles dances back in
like the 80s and 90s that I would hear
people go to and you know like okay hey
I'm here to meet someone and there's
like this weird desperation and
awkwardness whereas if you're at a film
festival or taking a writing class
you're engaged in something else and
then if naturally something happens or
you approach somebody that's a speaker
it just it seems like there's just a
different way there's less pressure
maybe yeah the nice thing a bit Yeah
because networking events I'm not saying
never go because there there is value in
them but it is exactly like that it's
speed dating and it's generally you
everyone is coming up to each other
going
how can you advance my career it's a
very self-centered way to meet people
it's I mean imagine if you were trying
to date somebody and you were going I'm
really looking for a wife or a husband
I mean the other person's gonna be like
uh sure slow down there Cowboy like I
don't even know your name right what do
you do Jason that's right yeah yeah and
I'm looking at your watch and the car
you're driving
you know if I'm and it happens you know
and I'm not even like
anybody and if people find out I'm a
director and then they're an actor
director like you just feel the energy
of like this
uh it's a it's a hard place
because everyone is essentially feeling
the same way now you know if I were in
that same plane and I've got actors
coming at me from this way but I look
over there and there's a
an investor
I'm not up to you
you want to make a movie you know it's
that same I mean it's human nature yeah
it is human so I think finding I think
in if you are at the networking event
there is a positive way to go about it
and I think that would be
to try to remove the desperation from it
go to the event without the mindset of I
have to get a job
just like you wouldn't go on a date
saying I have to find a partner
it just puts so much pressure on this
precious little connection that you're
trying to make
if you just remove that from the
equation and just say I'd like to just
make a friend
that is so much easier because you know
oddly enough some of the best
connections I've made at things like
that are usually someone like
the the person that's serving the hors
d'oeuvres you know like hit it off with
so-and-so and like isn't this whole
thing such a Croc you know man people
come down here they're so desperate
hahaha what do you do oh I'm you know my
name's Johnny and I I'm a DP and I
actually just I'm just doing this for
extra work what you are in a way you
know and then all of a sudden you're
friends oh it's so much easier
to do that do it that way to take the
pressure off this desperation but a film
festival or riding class those are great
because the focus is not on you as much
it's on
either their film or your film or
writing glass is a good one because it's
like you're focusing on a craft of like
getting better you're meeting other
people also with similar goals they're
all there to improve their craft and and
driving towards this direction not this
direction I mean yes we're all trying to
make it but we're all looking this way
and you just happen to be looking at the
person next to you and you're just kind
of becoming this
making a bond that way so it's a much
easier way to make friends and to build
a team
Jason when you were starting out in this
business what attitudes did you have
that were wrong
in terms of how the industry worked or
how to conduct yourself
in a meeting
[Music]
you know there's a saying that youth is
wasted on the young
I think what that saying means is that
we especially when we come out of film
school or school we
we just have this inflated sense of who
we are of how brilliant we are
that is the number one killer of careers
that I think that there is and just
having this over inflated sense of what
you can do
um
and I definitely suffered from that you
know because I
we all
who do this dreamed the big dream you
know we all watched that movie there was
probably a movie that you saw when you
were young and you were like
I can do that and we all and it's
probably true that's the thing
and then we just
start to build this framework of who we
are as people and then you actually get
into the world and start to try to work
and nobody looks at you like that
especially because well what have you
done you're just you're 20. you know uh
that really was um
was a blow uh
having a more of an ego than I deserved
if that makes sense you know
I think
I never and one of the things that
really
tripped me up for years and it still has
Ripple effects to this day is that I
didn't understand the importance of a
mentor
how much time that would have saved me
if I had just found someone to tell me
what to do because I had no idea we're
just stumbling around in the dark
uh
like how do you get the first job on set
who no one told me how to do that so
years had spent trying to figure out
even how to get an internship like my
God it's so hard so being humble enough
to just say
please give me some advice because I'm
I'm just want to learn
you know that kind of thing it's so
those are both probably fall under the
humility umbrella as far as the things
that I did wrong
um
I also think that there is a
that's the best way to say this
putting too much importance on
this I'm going to direct this two minute
short or whatever and putting so much
importance on it that you end up it it
ends up breaking under the pressure like
just
getting so wound up and so full of
anxiety over this one little opportunity
that you have that you end up locking
out all of the creativity you become
Vision locked into something that isn't
working you know that kind of thing
can really kill you
um
yeah uh because you want it so bad yes
and you're so you because you want it so
bad and because you
want to do it right
and
and to eat
there is a real pressure to the fear of
making a mistake
um
and that is something I wish that I
could have understood a lot earlier is
that it's is if I wish someone would
have come to me and said it's all right
to mess up sometimes you know if you
look at some of the greatest moments in
cinematic history they were generally
mistakes you know or improv lines from
an actor or some sort of something
didn't go quite right and that's the
thing that's on the film because it just
had this real magical to it
when you're putting so much pressure on
making it absolutely perfect like you
and Afraid of the mistake you just kill
all your creativity that's such a
dangerous spot to be
um
I wish someone would have told me that
and I think
one of the things I've noticed from
filmmakers who are very successful
is they have this very simple work ethic
that no one taught me that I wish I had
known
and that is like for example I I know a
couple screenwriters and they're I
they're
work ethic is almost identical they have
a set time they get up every day
and they
do their morning routine whatever it is
brush your teeth work out whatever
turn off their phones and for a couple
of hours block they write right and
right and right and right and right
after the end of that little block of
time whatever they said usually it's at
least an hour or more
they take a break they take their lunch
they turn their phone back on they check
their Facebook and whatever
and then they turn it off again and they
write and they write and they write and
they write and they write and then they
cut it off and now they're free to relax
I I don't think I've ever even heard of
that done in any kind of filmmaking
class no one ever said to me like you
need to be
super disciplined and guarded with your
time
to make sure that you are honing
practicing working on your craft for set
hours every single day
I didn't do that man a long time long
time years so
in those years they slip in they slip by
and suddenly it's a decade and you just
aren't getting better you're stagnating
you're circling things right so I wish
someone would have mentioned that
early on because it would have also
really helped this is how people when
they break through at Young ages it's
because they've been more disciplined
about that kind of thing I'm convinced
of that where you see them come out of
the gate and it's like dang how did this
guy get so good at 25. probably because
they were more disciplined
very focused on
their craft
that means being all alone probably
working on a script
studying reading without looking at
their phones and all of that kind of
stuff
but when you're young
and you're thinking about dating or
whatever it is the distractions of life
it's it really will get in the way of
of your progress it'll just make it take
a lot longer
um I knew someone who didn't have a cell
phone when they first came out because
they had such
pressure on them to be accountable for
certain people that they wanted their
time in the car to be uninterrupted and
everyone would go why doesn't this
person have a cell phone and the person
would say that's my time
when I'm driving you know this is before
you know driving on you know with that
this was this is early on when before it
was this taboo as it is now in dangerous
but they were just like no that's my
time
and and that's what I'm thinking that's
where I'm doing things I need to do for
for my day and I don't want to be
disturbed
I think that's super vital you know it's
really interesting to me because this is
something that I've fought for in a nice
and simultaneously struggle with is this
idea of I'm going to take from 8 AM to
10 a.m and I'm going to work my craft
oftentimes for me that's writing
something but
the minute I do that the minute I
hit do not disturb my phone
and start hitting keys
my eyes drift over to that phone and I
want to see if anyone's messaged me it
is unbelievable that's called resistance
and it is a sneaky little bastard like
it
uh it's it's I don't know where I think
it comes from a lot of places for a lot
of people like fear of success whatever
you want to call it but it is Sinister
um
the
self-discipline that it takes to
actually go no I'm going to take this
phone I'm going to put it in the other
room and I'm going to focus I'm going to
turn off my email turn off the messages
on my laptop turn off social media and
I'm going to focus on my craft for this
too straight over I actually got an
hourglass
that has a one hour
um timer on it I just flip it over and
I'll watch the sand go through and force
myself to do it but every day it's a
struggle every single day that
resistance thing wants to fight you
um
but consistently the people I know who
have broken through did that and they
did that for years where and what's
crazy is
going back to what I said at the
beginning they create an enormous volume
of work because they're so dedicated if
you're finding yourself where you're
working all day long on whatever it is
that you're working on it's probably
some sort of day job that you don't love
and then you sit down to write a
screenplay that night for like 30
minutes while you're checking Facebook
you're you're just gonna take
you're just extending it out you're just
like you're gonna take 30 years to
actually get a meeting at that rate
um
yeah so
I think it's important to pay attention
to that resistance
because it looks like different things
to different people
also do some people for people Pleasers
they have the people-pleasing disease
and they want to be able to be there for
individuals you know they want to be
present for friends and family but um
there can be demands so yeah yeah
this business this business is
I found that there is this intense
amount of anxiety attached to this
industry I think there's a lot of that
attached to life in general
um this is not just me talking but if
you look at societies worldwide
um
and the amount of people who feel
anxiety depression and those kinds of
things there is so many people taking
antidepressants so many people dealing
with this that they find traces of it in
the drinking water
and we've seen that I mean it's very
well known in La there's so many people
on Prozac or whatever that
um it's secreted and it ends up
you know that's why we have to have
filters on all our sinks because it's
all in there
well what's going on why is there so
many people so anxious and so stressed
out and so depressed I think that that
that's already there
and then it's exponentially harder in
our own industry and I think that that
comes from
and I hate this part of our industry
this comes from this place where there's
there's definitely a looking down the
nose at certain kinds of projects so
like if you I'll give you a perfect
example I was years ago I was looking at
joining the DGA
and my bread and butter oftentimes is
doing commercial corporate stuff and a
lot of that's non-union but that pays it
keeps the lights on keeps keeps me
working and it's it's actually great it
can be really great fun work and
fulfilling work
um
I asked them
so if I go Union can I still do
non-union work and they're like well
it's probably not a good idea
I'm like man I don't know if it's a good
idea for me to join at this point
because I can't just stop working what
am I gonna do go bag groceries until I
get a union job and they said to me
when you decide to take your career
seriously then you go ahead and come on
and sign up with us that right there is
exactly what I'm talking about it's this
little bit of arrogance with these
projects over here are legit
Marvel movie whatever you you know
high-end music video Marvel whatever you
you have these little category of movies
you know movies I've heard of or a TV
show that I've heard of
these are the legit ones everything else
over here if you're making a wedding
video or a whatever like those aren't
legit those aren't considered and you're
and when people ask you that
anxiety-induced question what are you
working on and the only thing you're
working on is a Colgate commercial it's
this flood of anxiety that comes up it's
everyone I know struggles with it they
struggle with it especially when they're
not working
you know when you haven't when you're
going to that event or even to a
friend's house because you know that the
question is inevitably coming what are
you working on and if you haven't been
working
what are you going to say like it is so
oh it just it just fuels us all and even
people I know who work a lot struggle
with the same thing
and I've spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what that is and how to how
to work with it and I do think there are
ways to fight it
um
I think the number one thing is
changing your relationship to anxiety
because when we experience it when it
crops up
we see it as a negative right it doesn't
feel comfortable
uh
there is a method in that I've heard
that I've practiced through meditation
called noting and that means
when you feel the negative feeling or I
shouldn't say negative the feeling of
anxiety comes out to take one second and
step back from it and go okay
I'm experienced anxiety
is this positive or negative anxiety
positive because there is positive
anxiety positive anxiety would be like
oh I got this big pitch meeting tomorrow
at HBO
or you know my film's in the contest I
hope I win that's positive that's cool
like I'm about to screen something oh I
hope my friends like it
that's exciting right that's a good kind
of anxiety and when you're experiencing
it and you're taking a second to look at
it and go oh well of course I'm on edge
because
my film's about to scream this is that's
a good that's okay and it's okay to feel
that there's also negative anxiety you
know like why Won't Anyone hire me you
know things like that
now when you note
these feelings it's I think really vital
to not judge it it you are not trying to
change it you are just recognizing it
I'm feeling anxious because rent is due
and I haven't been working okay well you
know what that's a rational fear that is
you know of course who wouldn't feel
anxious there's something about just
giving yourself a little permission in
some of those cases to just be okay with
it okay yeah this is a real threat you
know I need a place to live or whatever
because you don't want to get into the
Trap of being anxious because you're
anxious because that just does this
right so noting like just recognizing it
and then changing your relationship to
what it is
um you can also uh take a look at it and
is this a thinking or feeling
kind of you know thinking would be rent
is due
you know this is a faction it's due on
the first and I don't have it that's a
fact feeling is
man every time it gets cloudy and rainy
I just feel down like that's a feeling
so again you're not changing it you're
just changing your relationship to it
when it rears its ugly head and going oh
it's a it's a negative feeling and it's
just a feeling
okay
well you know what I like hot chocolate
I'm gonna go get one of those and just
recognize it for what it is I'm not
going to try to change it I'm just going
to be okay with it I think that's a
that's a huge huge first step of dealing
with it
um
the second thing I would say is that
you really need to pay attention to the
people that you hang around with because
you know they say misery loves company
and what that means is
when you get into a whiny mood like
finding other people to whine with
there's a lot of power in that and it
all it does is it it just feeds on
itself it becomes the Sloop and you can
end up becoming more angry and more
frustrated
I would say
challenge yourself to to be around
people who are relentlessly optimistic
or try to change your group's mindset to
hey you know I know we're frustrated
that we haven't been working but
what if we just made something ourselves
you know in fuel some hope into this
group that you're in if you can't change
your group right
or find a different group I think that's
super super important
um
the third thing I would say that I I
think this has been a big one for me is
that
um they say that the number one way to
fight feelings of anxiety is to find a
community
anxiety loves it when you're alone
you know depressed people when people
commit suicide they're not in groups
they're by themselves
there's reason for that you know
one of the best ways is if you're
surrounded by people who especially in
an optimistic positive
environment and I would say
that
this group
shouldn't be filmmakers
somewhere else
now I think and it's even better if it's
active like something physical but it
can be
kickball league or knitting or martial
arts or ballroom dance or horseback
riding just some sort of community
regular Community activity where you are
plugged into a bigger family of people
that's not filmmaking related is so
incredibly powerful
um
I personally I found Jiu Jitsu that was
my Big it really helped me a lot and
because in Jiu Jitsu I took it for
self-defense
um
they say that judges is one of the best
martial arts for self-defense uh because
in street fights things generally go to
the ground
and when you're on the ground how do you
deal with someone on top of you trying
to choke you
so I started getting into that and
the thing that's here's what happens
in my own Journey
I'll be anxious about something you know
anxiety rears its head ah why did I get
that job or whatever
I won't want to go
it's one of my buddies from class will
go dude bro you coming
yeah I'll be there I go to class I'm
feeling I'm sitting in the car in the
parking lot ah I should go home and work
on that script or whatever no I'm the
class is starting in two minutes I'll go
in I go in
the minute I hit the mat
and so some kid is on my back trying to
actively choke me guess what I'm not
thinking about anymore I'm not thinking
about the fact that that agent never
called me back I'm not thinking about
the thing that's due tomorrow I'm
thinking about not getting choked by
this animal that's behind me you know
that is and when I'm done and it's a not
only is it an amazing physical sport
like you are exhausted by the end but
it's a huge endorphin dump you're just
like foom and you're around a whole
community of people who are learning a
skill getting better focusing on
something else they're making their
lives better these are people they all
have their own interesting and Rich
lives you are out of that artist
Community for just a second and you're
just enjoying some great social time in
another group I come back from that and
I am super charged when it comes back oh
oftentimes I'm on my way home like I
know what to say to that guy to get him
to call me back yes that's what I'm
gonna you know it's I'm usually on a
huge Euphoria high at the end of it
community community community is so
important like I would highly recommend
and I know that the first step to doing
that it's always hard like to
they say in Jiu Jitsu the hardest spell
to get is the white belt because it's
forcing yourself out of the house into
this straight group of strangers for the
first time but man
please
go out and get that done
um
and finally I would say when you if you
find yourself dealing with it there is a
lot of comfort in the fact that if you
are to to make sure that you are working
on your craft
continuing to make progress every day uh
there is a lot of comfort when
you get to the end of a year and realize
you wrote three screenplays that year
you know that's
that feels really good or you took a
whole writing class and graduated or
whatever it is like that if you are not
continually like getting better and
practicing and feeling yourself improved
you know that feels really good that
that can also because you'll know at the
end of the day
at five o'clock when you log off and you
decide to stop and put writing aside for
a minute
you can go play video games in peace
because you put in the work that feels
nice you can relax because you know you
did your work for the day that that's a
really satisfying
feeling
did you ever need to use any of the
moves in Jiu Jitsu in real life in real
life
uh let me think you know well
interesting story so
in my own journey I I had some very
aggressive fathers so my both were
bullish both had a lot of street fights
so as a kid I grew up feeling utterly
powerless
this really carried over in a career by
the way like as I would approach people
that I was intimidated by like that
inner feeling of powerlessness was
really strong and so
when I went into Jiu-Jitsu I was
absolutely terrified like to
I was essentially finding My Own
Strength
uh
I was taking class for about a year
and a lot of at least the school that I
attend is all about self-defense it's
just someone on the street comes up to
you and does this
you know here's some things you can do
at least to keep yourself safe
anytime I'd ever been in an aggressive
situation
it looked like something was about
standing in a bus stop in some
aggressive
was going to come up I'm absolutely
terrified and and wish I could run away
right before the very first day of
shooting the abandoned my last feature
I hear a crash downstairs in the house
that we're staying in
it's three o'clock in the morning
I get up out of bed I'm totally drowsy
my dog is freaking out
I walk downstairs and there's a guy
standing in the kitchen
now
it was the weirdest most surreal thing
because
I was I was still just a very new
practitioner of Jiu Jitsu I didn't you
know I'm no I'm no badass
but it was the first time in my life
where I'm faced with a potential
aggressive person
and I felt peace because
the way the guy the guy was standing in
the kitchen leaning on the counter kind
of hunched I thought he was going to
rush me
um
but I'd been practicing what happens
when someone rushes you in class for a
year so
I just in that moment I just looked at
him and I thought okay well if he rushes
me that's okay
I know how to deal with this I can at
least keep him from getting to anyone
else in the house while they call the
police or whatever
we can get this handled so
in the end it turns out he was drunk and
he found himself in the wrong house now
I didn't know this at the in that first
half the second when I saw him in the
kitchen you know for a couple of minutes
there it was real Touch and Go
prior to that I probably would have
grabbed the knife or
freaked out or whatever but
it really did in a very positive way
change
um it was a great way to start shooting
the movie
you know uh to just have that calmness
you know in the face of that kind of
adversity was was really
it was really great and it could be
inspiration for your next script I mean
how bizarre is that did someone
accidentally goes into the wrong house
but I guess
right we all look the same I don't know
when it comes to inspiration for that I
mean I have will say that when you learn
some when you get involved with some
other sport or some other
skill you're increasing your skills in
some other way it really does fuel ideas
like
you know if you whatever horseback
riding class you're gonna be on that
horseback riding you're going to be
riding that horse you're gonna be
thinking man wouldn't it be cool to
write a story about someone on a horse
who's
or whatever it's going to happen it just
will if you're an artist you know that's
that's one of the advantages to doing
that but yeah
glad everything was okay yeah oh yeah
yeah
when did you begin to realize that if
you poured all of your energy and
passion into your art that one day
someone would give you a job when did I
realize
or that you'd be discovered yeah
yeah you know that's a real that's an
interesting question because
it comes down to the definition of the
word discovered you know what does
discovered mean
I would say that I as a kid and I think
probably every filmmaker watching this
probably feels this way
you look at
whatever Raiders of the Lost Ark and you
go I could do that
I wonder if anyone else believes I can
do that like it's I know I have to
convince the world that I can actually
do it
now in my case
the people that
have
believed in me and given me the shot
have not been the people I expected so
uh it was came it'd be like a best
friend who just happened to be in a
position that they could hire me they
just like came from back here and you're
like wait what you're gonna
that's when
I was hope it was like it was one of
those things where I always felt like I
had something to contribute something to
give
I was just wondering how long it was
going to take for anyone to actually
notice you know what I mean it's almost
the other way around it's like I always
but I think we're all that way we all
feel that way we all feel like we have
something special and you're just
waiting for the world to catch up to
where we are
um that could be a frustrating position
especially if you feel like no one's
discovered you yet but um I have always
found that when it does happen
and no matter which level you're on it
does happen and that that could mean a
movie deal or it could mean getting a
nice job you know dragging a commercial
it always comes from the last place I
expected usually a friend or a contact
of some sort
um
yeah so
yeah and I think
that yeah it comes down to that
maddening place of
how long is it going to take for
everyone else to discover what I can do
this is where and this is where it's so
important to
continue to create and put out there
stuff that you
can do there's a great quote from Ira
Glass uh who is the host of or the
creator of This American Life and he
talks about how when we got into the art
whatever it is that we got into
um
we all got into it because we have
killer taste and we always felt like we
could do
this XYZ thing
um and then we start to create it
and we realize there's this gap between
what we're creating and what we like
and we see that Gap because we have good
taste and the only way to close that Gap
is to continue to create work
lots of work thousands of hours
and that's the only way to close that
Gap and if you find yourself not
creating anything and and you're in this
business just toiling away editing
reality television for years and years
and years and never actually making
anything then you should probably you're
never going to close that Gap unless you
do it that is how people will discover
you because the more you do it the
better you're gonna get
and eventually law of averages says that
that is what will happen
come back and ask me in a year and we'll
see you know and Spielberg is called
yeah we'll see if that actually pays off
but
um
that's how it's worked so far
notion of being discovered is is sort of
an old term you know I'm sort of
thinking of you know like a talent show
from the 80s where you're going to be
picked and you're going places kid but
it almost seems like now they want to
see how much work of your own have you
put in without someone picking you
it seems like things have changed a lot
there has been a change while the one
thing that's changed I think is that
um the ability to create amazing stuff
is is has come down to other levels
where you can reach it because you know
back in the day
to create anything that looked any good
you'd have to rent these really
expensive cameras and big lights and
stuff you don't have to do that anymore
I mean it's just the way iPhones shoot
looks amazing like really amazing so
there is still I think the Divide
between
the the threshold of
television movies you know working with
Disney on a thing that people have heard
of there is that little divide so that
still exists
and there's there's that stuff and then
there's everything else
but
there is still so much amazing work out
there to be had you know they're still
and you can be I the discovery can
happen on those other little projects
um
and that is I think it's uh
really fun to do it because
like for example I do a lot of work with
hospitals and hospitals a lot of times
hire me to create these little stories
and I'm telling you they are so much fun
to do because they're little
short films that are usually really
meaningful really heartfelt you're
working with actors and and it is you're
making a little movie you get great
practice and it is super super fun
uh and I was discovered
from that based on you know people that
I knew and and just doing little shorts
of my own like they would they would see
a little short film or whatever it hits
a festival or something and then they go
we should hire that guy to bring do our
little thing that's how all that stuff
happened so you could call that a
discovery now is it gonna win an Academy
Award no
but that's okay there's nothing wrong
with that I'm I'm doing what I dreamed
of doing as a kid and it is a blast and
you know people may watch this and go oh
that guy's never made a multi-million
dollar thing okay you're right I have it
but I'm having a freaking great time
making and telling stories and moving
people it is it is just
it is the most fun career that you can
have because you're telling stories and
you're taking audiences on a ride
no matter where you're doing it whether
that's a wedding video or completely on
the opposite end with a Marvel film
you're doing the same job and it is
really great so yeah it's uh
I don't know that answered your original
question about being discovered but I do
think that there is a when they're
trusting you with
telling the story for their brand or for
their whatever uh
there is a discovery process that does
need to happen they need to see that you
have the talent to actually manipulate
and tell a story and craft a narrative
in a way that wraps up what they're
trying to sell or do or say
for it so hence the sort of corporate
video that was in um Jurassic Park I
think also in Blade Runner too didn't
they have a few like they'd have these
Billboards yeah these commercials well
that's right I mean most times when you
see a Sci-Fi act you know stuff like
that fantasy they'll have some sort of
way to communicate information
um
that's that's corporate video one-on-one
right there
and heck
what better way to practice you know if
you are gonna let's just say you could
look at your life from beginning to end
and you knew that in I don't know 10
years you were going to get to direct
the next Blade Runner
well
wouldn't it be good to practice and you
know that in that Blade Runner there's
going to be a whole time travel element
that you're gonna have to fold into it
and explain to an audience how it works
wouldn't it be good to like kind of
practice that now with your with at T
client that you have or or whatever you
know like it would it be good to like
kind of maybe
because if you mess that up
who cares you know it's just the
corporate video that not a lot of people
are going to see
wouldn't that be much better to do it
that way and then by the time you get to
Blade Runner sequel oh man I got this
I've been doing that this is going to be
fun and now I have all the money to do
it like that's a great way to look at it
you know why did you see the Apple
commercial around 1984. it's just one
where they throw the thing into the
screen yes I think so right directed by
Ridley Scott
yeah that would that
that Apple commercial
isn't that crazy it has this amazing
look this really cool story it never it
aired one time on television I believe
and this is pre-internet
and it made so many Ripples and it
really made Ridley Scott's career like
from there he went on and did I think I
think alien was after that
you might have done the Duelist at that
point but yeah that was because really
Scott was a commercial director before
he became
uh doing movies
so
yeah
I was Finding work in Los Angeles as a
director different from other places
yeah that's a good question so I've
lived quite a few different places
around the country
um
I just grew up in Portland Oregon I
lived in Nashville for many years I went
to I've lived in Eastern Washington I
lived back in Portland and tend to La
every single city in the country has
their own little interesting if you do
film it has their own little interesting
Hub
um
for the most part most cities have like
some sort of Industry that keeps it
going
um
like in Portland and Seattle there's you
know you got Microsoft and Nike and
Adidas excuse me a bunch of ad agencies
there
so the for the most part A lot of the
work that people do
is in that
realm uh so I mean you can have a great
career just doing Microsoft videos and
you know there's no shame in that and
that's sort of the industry that it's
going to be and the only difference
between that and like in Nashville is
replace Microsoft with music videos
it's the same kind of thing probably a
smaller more tight-knit Film Community
doing similar kind of stuff and also
great careers can be had by doing that
uh I've recently been doing a lot of
work in Florida and Tampa and there
their industry is um
HGTV I believe yeah his base there so
they a lot of the people that work there
work there at doing and then I think
Ashley Furniture makes a lot of their
commercials there so almost everyone
I've worked with usually is spent some
time working in that little Realm
so moving from City to City that's not a
Hub City
that's the biggest difference it's
really just okay what industry is here
and then you know now if you're talking
indie film The indie film markets in
those towns look identical
which is kind of funny and there's
almost this funny little divide between
those who are doing the corporate work
like the doing the Microsoft stuff or
the Ad Agency world and then there's the
Indie filmmakers over here and usually
those two worlds don't intersect that
much in a weird way
now
I think there's a middle step as well
and that would be the Hub cities cities
like New Orleans and Atlanta and New
Mexico so in those cities tons and tons
of work is happening
if you are below the line
any kind of crew position makeup artists
and
whatever gaffer grips ACS all of that
stuff you will work you can work as much
as you want and you're working on great
big stuff you're probably going to be
able to really do quite well and that is
a if you want to work in movies and
even if you do want to be a director but
you're still you're starting out and
you're working your way up the ladder
those can be a great cities to go to
because it's it's like
I can I have a friend who just moved to
New Orleans a few years ago and he told
me when he first moved there he couldn't
believe
how much work was actually happening
they were doing a big movie and their
base camp where all the catering was
where you met in the morning was
actually shared by two other gigantic
Productions three of them sharing one
huge base camp like that's insane I
can't even imagine that and he said that
because boy if you live here you could
work as much as you want full-time
year-round full union rates all of it
like
you could just clean house and work and
work and work and work work
so that does exist in LA but it's a lot
harder to
to get
um
because everybody moves to LA
to pursue film so
everybody's a filmmaker your if you came
from
Kansas City and you were really good at
and you had that corner of the market on
the whatever is in Kansas City
you are really nothing special when you
get to LA
there will be it's not that you're not
talented it's just that everybody does
that here like everybody's like that
la
is those of you who don't live here like
the biggest difference is that La is
where the decisions happen so if you are
above the line
writers directors mainly and actors who
want to be on larger things
you got to be here
so getting
on those projects in an above the line
position is a whole different game than
anything else that you have to worry
about in other cities
all you got to do in say a Portland to
get work is
you're probably going to bid on it
by against a couple of production houses
that you're probably friends with you're
gonna hire them anyway once you get the
job so it doesn't matter but you're
probably bidding on it in some sort of
way uh
then you know the budgets are not gonna
yeah they may be all right but they're
not going to be Millions more than
likely
um
and yeah it's going to be a little a fun
little corporate thing and it's going to
be lower pressure I mean high pressure
for the client but overall the grand
scope of life not that big of a deal
La it's 100 different than that
you can work here
and most people do when they get here if
you're trying to get here and work as a
filmmaker yes there is work to be had is
it work that you want
that's the question that's the real
trick
um because most of the people that he
move here
well you got to work somewhere and
It generally will come down to do I work
waiting tables or do I work anywhere I
can get into the industry
um you know and that might be an
assistant too
some Rider
you're not you're not writing anything
but you're their assistant getting their
coffee it might be most of the people I
know go into reality somewhere some way
is it the dream job absolutely not do
they like it probably not for the most
part but that's there's a lot of that
kind of work below the line stuff you
might be running a camera you might be
producing but it's
is not the dream job at all so
it's a weird almost like purgatory
that exists here because this is giant
machine
and that's the best way to define it La
is an industry most of these other towns
are communities that's a huge Gulf of a
difference so when you're here you get
you can get stuck in this filmmaker
Purgatory of like constantly working on
stuff you don't like like reality shows
or whatever
and then you're making some money and
you're surviving but you cannot figure
out how to cross the threshold from that
to all right I'm going to hire you
because you're a great director to
direct on this television show or Helm
the next Marvel film like that's a
that's a much weirder barrier to cross
and that doesn't exist and if you don't
live here you're probably not going to
have to deal with that unless you're
incredibly lucky unless you just happen
to be the one guy who won that lottery
ticket and gets discovered
by the president of Disney and brings
you over
otherwise forget it it's probably not
going to happen so
that's a real trick a real weird
most filmmakers you meet in LA are in
purgatory they're in that weird
they're they're all writing something
they're all developing something they're
all all of us everyone I know they have
the thing they want to do they have no
idea how to get over that bridge but
they all want to do it
um
I think if you're going to move here
that is an important thing to understand
because you've got to work somewhere you
got to make a living
um
and I think if you understand going in
that your life will probably be taken
over by
uh
that purgatory
you have to continue then to keep
working on your own craft when you're
not on set doing this other thing over
here that is the key to figuring it out
is I've I gotta live I gotta make a
living somewhere
putting a barrier around that and going
when I'm not doing that then I'm going
to work on my thing every writer I know
who's got an agent they their agents
always tell them or managers tell them
the same thing yeah I know you're
working all day on that TV show and I
know you're tired but if you want
anything if you want to have a career of
your own at all you have to keep working
on your own stuff on the side they tell
them that straight up and every writer I
know does that they'll work all day on
their thing when they get home
they eat their dinner they sit in there
and they write for a couple hours on
their own passion projects and that is
how they break through that is how they
keep going forward
it's harder you know especially when you
get married you start having kids life
starts getting in the way and they find
the energy to do that is is the biggest
challenge
that leads me to my next question
because we have a quote from you that we
got from our 2019 interview that we did
with you what you do in the dark when no
one is looking
that's where your medal is
that's how you get better
do you still Embrace this idea yeah no
question about it I
yes it is
when you're in your when you're young
when you're in your teens in your 20s we
are all going to school
right we and then when we get out of
college most of us stop
why is that
why do we all stop learning
and taking classes and honing why do we
do that what is there is there like did
somebody on high like
flick a switch and say you've learned
all that you need to know no no
um
but we seem to always do that and the
only way to do that is
the self
discipline to continue on your own when
no one's looking all right
I'm not on Facebook
what can I learn what am I lacking in my
directing skills
gee I really suck at working with actors
I should probably get better at that how
do I do that well maybe read a couple of
books or take you know that's that's
where the real yes you you must do that
if you want to be the best you have to
do that
I was I was working on a show recently
this last year
and in the last couple of years I was in
a writing class
and uh
I started the writing class because I
just wanted to get better at crafting
stories it just understanding how
storytelling works on the most basic
level
it was an area that I felt was lacking
in my own journey and so I yeah I'm
gonna do this so at night I was
taking this class
landed this job and I'm directing all
these episodes and the executive
producer pulls me aside
and he says because you know there's
been a few people that have come up to
me and say and and said to me
why is the guy who's directing your show
taking a writing class at night
and he said to me he goes and they're
telling me this they're asking me this
like it's a negative and I said to them
are you crazy it's because he knows that
life's a journey that you have to keep
sharpening and honing and pushing all
the time otherwise you stagnate because
that he thinks that's why he's got the
job because he knows that not because he
goes I know everything
um it was such an interesting thing to
hear uh but that that's an insight into
how most of us think
like we get to a point where we think
we've mastered it and if you think that
you probably haven't
and do you think that that goes back to
what we talked about sort of I guess a
snobbery in this business because at
what point is anybody finished with
learning something yeah I think I can I
think I think a lot of the traditional
snobbery that we think of when we think
of Hollywood
I mean I think ultimately stems from
insecurity
you know this idea that
maybe I'm not if they were to be honest
in the dark maybe I'm not as good as I
think I am Maybe
I mean a lot of the people that have
treated me poorly were people that were
threatened by me and I'm not saying I'm
all that I'm just saying all of us have
experienced that where you just there's
someone that you run into that treats
you badly
and you almost know on this gut level
that it's like I think they're
threatened by me I don't even know why
I'm not trying to like hurt them I'm not
trying to beat them but they are viewing
me like I'm trying to be like so it all
stems from this deep deep insecurity I
think
um
that's really a shame and a lot of the
people I think who are the worst
offenders of that are the people that
don't continue to grow
they feel like this is where you'll hear
it too you'll hear it when it when
someone will complain about the young
coming up and taking their jobs that's
where you can really spot it that is
someone who has
uh it's a it's a growth mindset versus a
fixed mindset it's a fixed mindset is
someone who believes that Talent is
something you're born with
a growth mindset is some someone that
believes that Talent is something that
can be learned by continuing repeated
Behavior
now you may have a knack a propensity
for math or photography but that doesn't
mean you're a genius
out of the womb you know it has to be
cultivated and worked the people that
use those terms like
those kids don't know what they're doing
they don't want to hire an expert well
no it's not that it's probably not that
at all it's because they're hungry
they're they're coming up and and
fighting for it to learn and they're
probably they're the ones watching film
courage interviews to get better the
people that are angry are not they're
not they're just not
now they're all going to comment on on
this one and say what's that kind of but
uh it's
yeah that's uh I think that's where that
comes from though I that
and I think if you are one of those
people and you're constantly feeling
this threat
uh it's time to take a serious look at
where you are standing and where those
feelings are really coming from are you
feeling threatened because you're
worried about your job
and if you're worried about your job why
are you so worried is it because you
think that they're going to discover you
for being a fraud maybe or is it because
um I don't know like
there's many reasons why that could be I
just think
it's it's time for self-reflection time
should you find yourself in that
position I think we can all think back
to when we were threatened of someone I
mean I can picture being 14 and being
incredibly threatened of somebody and
now that I look back on it it was
because yeah I was afraid they were
gonna you know it was my little
part-time job and then I thought they
were going to take my job and they
weren't they were just there for the
summer yeah before they went to college
but you know it's if we look back to
things when when we did it you know we
can say okay well that was why I
couldn't say hi to this you know and
then and then when it happens to you in
reverse then you go okay that's a fair
point it is a fair point because yes
I've struggled with that too there's
certainly directors have come up that
I'm like frustrated with like
but if I'm being honest I would say it's
because
I I could even I mean it's been it's
happened I'll see some 20 year old
do something that I can't do
that bothers me
because you know whatever and it's who
knows they spent all their high school
years we're learning After Effects and
they just got really good at doing VFX
and they're coming out of the gate with
some amazing short that's like
how in the world did he and I feel
threatened by that and I want to treat
them badly because of that I think it's
just uh that's not
instead wouldn't it be better and I'm
talking to myself here but wouldn't it
be better for me to take a look at this
person and go maybe we should team up
wouldn't it be cool to like take someone
who's got that desire and has the skill
that I struggle with and to bring them
onto my team and we can work together I
mean this is a collaborative art after
all isn't that the way it's
supposed to work like you're taking all
these artists who are hungry do you know
how much that would mean to him or her
if you did that and how hard they would
work because chances are they are
looking at you as you know a veteran or
whatever
wanting that approval and and just
begging for a shot
um
I think it would be a much healthier way
of looking at it
uh because think about it that's what we
all want that's what we all wanted we
all want someone to believe in us and
not be threatened by us and give us a
shot so
um
you know
and it actually makes me wonder if the
those of us who feel threatened who feel
angry who who if we feel like well no
one ever helped me why should I help
them yeah or maybe I don't
have anything to give them because I
never did get a shot so they're gonna
just surpass me
you know those are all
hard questions to
to process
um
I think if you recognize that that's how
you're feeling
it's time for reality check on you know
maybe maybe you have gotten shots and
maybe you are further than you think
maybe you are
someone of influence that does have a
lot to give you know and holding on so
tightly to your position is is I think
it's like a cancer because it because
when you do that this gets back to what
we were talking about originally holding
on to something when it's trying life is
trying to slip past and morph it in your
hands
maybe it could grow into something even
more incredible than you you're
imagining right now you know like
whenever you start to feel that gut go
and hold on to that thing like I think
that's that's a Thai time to like take a
serious look at where you are
do you have to be a genius to create a
masterpiece
oh do I have to be a genius to make up
no I don't think so you know it's
here's the great thing about this
industry is that it's collaborative I
think that there's a lot of
people if you look at some of these
movies that I think one of the classic
examples is Casablanca it was an
absolute disaster in the making of but
somehow the pieces magically fell
together to create this incredible thing
and that can happen I mean there's a lot
of I won't name names but you there's a
lot of directors that do one great film
and they're the rest of their films are
just terrible and you're like how in the
world did that first one
end up so good and the rest of these are
so bad is probably a lot of it's because
they were probably had this amazing
support team around them
to help carry them wrong and that's one
of the I'd say advantages to directing
is that
I'm not advocating for this but you you
can do it and not know what you're doing
and actually it happens it's very common
it's very common because think about it
like if your DP knows his stuff or her
stuff
he did you know your director doesn't
have to
know where to put the camera if you have
amazing actors and they're just spot on
with they just know how to do it and
you're
you know your production designer is
amazing you know you director you know
you can phone it in and be fine like
your other departments will carry you
there's a great comfort in that actually
like if you come in and you have no idea
how to shoot the scene and your DP is
amazing well they will help you so no
you don't have to be a genius
um
and I I think there's a comfort in that
because you know the insecure that maybe
the potential insecurity that's there of
ooh what if I don't really know what I'm
doing I think not all of us struggle
with that but I definitely think that's
a thing I remember hearing an interview
with um
the guy who the the composer for
Gladiator and Dark Knight and uh Hans
Zimmerman
I remember hearing an interview with him
years ago where he said wow I just
landed this job I think it was the job
for Gladiator he's like wow like wow I
just landed the job to do the score for
Gladiator I hope no one discovers that
I'm a fake
it's like what really you think that and
I know there's a lot of people very
accomplished people who have the same
thought of what if what if I'm not a
genius what if
there's some flaw in me that is going to
keep me from getting to
up there
um
no you don't have to be so this is where
it becomes really important to make sure
you're surrounded by the absolute best
you know really talented artists and
filmmakers and that's that's awesome in
filmmaking you know it's a really
positive thing when your DP is better
than you are
uh wow that's cool I've worked with
actors who I can tell would be amazing
directors and they have such good
instincts they're out directing me
sometimes
I could choose to be insecure about that
but better to go
you know that's actually a pretty good
idea let's do that I like your idea nice
one dude so that's that's a really uh I
think uh
that's a good thing now
that doesn't mean we shouldn't try that
doesn't mean that doesn't give us
permission to just phone it in I do
think that we need to bring our a game
and be prepared
when we're
when we're working
um but no genius
now you can there's lots of people
working today that
probably shouldn't be there but you know
that's okay it's all right that right
there is the number one skill that a
director needs to have is how to out
think all the problems all the time
because they are coming at you a
thousand miles an hour and when it's
going great and things are all running
in the same direction that's awesome but
when you
when you're faced with the worst
that's where the Testament of how good
you are really will come true
um when we did Kenobi
we were shooting out in the Trona
Pinnacles which is
it's Central California it's kind of
Near Death Valley and it's this it's uh
there's not a lot out there there's this
land with these big it's a magical
looking place these big spiers sticking
up out of nowhere but you know we're
three hours or more from LA
everyone came in on this bus
and it's a TR it's a lot of people out
there doing all of this stuff and a lot
of not just it's not just a love story
or something simple it is droids and
Stormtroopers and stunt guys and like
all the I mean a million different
children you know and keep in mind the
Stormtroopers can't hear you when
they're when you're trying to direct
them and they can't because the helmet
you can't hear anything you also can't
see anything because you're you you have
this much to see
first day
we had wind gusts up to 30 40 miles an
hour
and so I realized I couldn't shoot
anything that involved dialogue
okay
so how am I gonna deal with that and
then the props truck got into a car
accident on the way to set so we had no
droids we had no speeder we had no we
had this big moisture evaporator Tower
didn't have any that didn't show up all
I have are some actors and high winds
so that is a perfect example of
all the plans that I had made all the
storyboards and shot lists that I had
all went right out the window because
all of a sudden I have nothing to shoot
like we can go over here and do this oh
no we can't because it's too windy
okay so all of a sudden I was forced to
severely think on my feet and basically
rebuild the whole film in my head and we
started by shooting inserts
which is the complete backwards way
you're supposed to do it when you're
doing a a scene or show or something you
generally start with your master your
coverage and then you figure out oh we
need the guy pulling the wallet out well
this had to be the total opposite of
that it was I could get away with like
one line of dialogue or something like
there's a shot in there if you've seen
it where Aunt baru as she's binocular
she turns to the camera the camera
pushes out behind her and she goes
stronger
um that was during that day because I
had it was one line we would sit there
we get the camera set up we're waiting
and the wind would go
action dang hit the shot and then that's
it
um then the next day we had a little kid
on set and he was so little that he
didn't he wasn't quite old enough to
really understand it he was on a set
so
it to him it's play time and costume
um very it makes it really hard he's one
of the youngest actors I've ever
directed so it makes it hard to to you
know how do you to handle because you
can't be super rigid about your schedule
and you're shot list because he's he's
going to be the way he wants to be and
you know he's afraid of the
Stormtroopers and starts crying and you
know it's just like uh so
your ability as a director to think on
your feet is super vital
that's what that job required the ways
that you can fight that the ways that
you can fight maybe is the wrong word
the way you can prepare for that
um because it will happen to you if
eventually there will be days where
things are going to go completely wrong
first is to prepare more than you even
think you need to like having as many
detailed shot lists or storyboards that
you can come up with is super helpful
especially for something like that where
it's very complex lots of moving pieces
costumes actors kids
really knowing what you if you get on
set and you're going to be gone
you're thinking you're going to figure
it out on the day or to put the camera
that's a very dangerous spot to be
because that may happen anyway whether
you want it to or not so at least having
an idea before you get there is really
good
but even that's not enough like
understanding
I need to have this standoff between
these two people I want to start with
this wide drone shot coming down then I
want to get this over the shoulder but I
really want to get this intimacy between
these two people whatever it is
um I think that
having
a
very strong background in editing
is the
I won't say number one I will say that's
probably the number two skill that you
need as a director is really knowing
how to cut a scene in your head
while you're working because it does
happens all the time where you'll be on
set
do we have the scene
hang on so we got him we got him got the
master you know we never did we never
got him pulling the thing out of his
pocket we should get that
but then maybe the sun's going down you
have time for one shot how are you gonna
get that and get your scene
um
that there is no other way to really get
good at that unless you're editing
spending thousands and thousands and
thousands of hours in an edit Suite
putting together other people's things
because then it'll just it'll ingrain in
you a reflex of what you're going to
actually need on set
um if you don't have that you're just at
a such a disadvantage
um if you're in the position like
personally I hate being in the position
of not knowing something of not
understanding how a camera works I don't
like that like I don't understand not
understanding the difference between an
85 and a 35 lens like what does that
mean if you find yourself in that
position I think it's really important
to spend some time in the camera
Department to figure it out because it
just Smooths it out for you so much when
you're there so when it comes to editing
really having an understanding of that
so in Kenobi is a perfect example
the last because we had so many problems
from the weather and everything coming
in
the last half of the last day of that
was the most insane day I've ever
experienced on set it was ours we were
in a bowl
the Sun is going down and when it's down
you're done period and you there was
money on the line there was an investor
that several investors that had ponied
up large sums of money to make sure this
happened and you better get it done
you better get it done it's like no and
you are in the pressure cooker you are
it's go time so no time to like not know
what to do
we were
I had to go
okay we have to kill the bad guy go here
go here you know throw the lightsaber
One Shot Two takes done move on and we
were like leap frogging into certain
sets and the final fight scene when he
does the big lightsaber thing we
actually ran out of sun
the sun went down and dipped behind the
little bowl that we were in so we ran
out to another location
where we could still see just like a
foot of sun on the horizon just a little
bit and it was two circles around him
one wide one tight and that's it but I
knew because I'd spent so long editing
that we that that would give us enough
to get us the story we just barely got
it
um
that that is such a huge skill that
that's necessary
so the first one was being able to think
on your feet you said and then the
second skill a good director should have
is just being very proficient with
editing yes really understanding editing
I think the third skill and this I would
say is number one and it's knowing how
to work with actors
and I am continually shocked at
how that is a skill that most directors
don't seem to know I don't understand
why that one is the
one that's shoved aside
just today A friend of mine who's a DP
said that um
she said they're working with an actor
the lead of this movie and the lead is
not good and I said
well hopefully your director can direct
the actor and and bring up a good
performance and he said or she said
no the director's giving no notes
whatsoever
like he's he's working with the camera
Department
and the actors left on their own the
amount of time is unbelievable the
amount of times I hear actors complain
about this
I went out there I'm doing my thing I'm
getting no notes I have no idea what I'm
doing you know if you understand what
it's like to be an actor it's like
painting blindfolded you're out there
performing but you can't see it
and if your director is hiding in video
Village back there
not telling you
that is a it's a very
it's a very frustrating place to be as
an actor and um
it just astounds me that more directors
don't spend more time learning the skill
and it seems to be this
Terror when it comes to it
this idea that working with an actor is
scary
uh
I'm not sure where that idea comes from
I worked with an actor I was a rather a
director friend of mine
a couple years ago was helping her out
on set and she said
she said I heard her say this is someone
else she goes well this actors worked
with Martin Scorsese what do I have to
say I'm like
what do you mean what do you have you're
the director they want to hear what you
have to say it doesn't they don't care
that you are not Martin Scorsese they
just need to know what you want so
the most common excuse I hear from
directors when it comes to this kind of
subject is they always say that oh well
um just cast the right person and that
will solve your problems well first of
all I think that's a terrible uh
philosophy to have because what that is
saying is
well I'm just going to make sure that
I'm going to hire the right person so
that they can do the hard work
that's taking all of the pressure off of
you and throwing it on someone else so
that you can just get out of actually
preparing and learning how to do it
second of all it's completely
unrealistic do you know how many
projects there when you're working on
something you are always going to have
the one person that you didn't cast the
the
I was working on a commercial one time
and uh I picked this act I thought this
actor was really good and they had this
great presence to them the client said
no we want this other guy
and I was like
I don't think this guy has any
experience I think he's kind of new and
in his audition
he didn't even read the lines they cast
him because of his look
so he gets to set so I have no choice
this is the guy I have to work with
um he shows up and sure enough it was
his first time on set all right so now
the philosophy of
just cast the right people suddenly
that's gone and now what are you gonna
do well what are you gonna do so
I mean the amount of films that are made
where the investor says I'll give you
the money for your movie but I'm gonna
put my daughter in the lead
has your daughter ever acted well no but
you got a movie and you just have to
make my daughter look good okay so then
how do you do it how do you work with
the actor oh oh no the actor they're so
scary
um
actors are a different Beast
they behave differently than everyone
else on set it's like they're like the
popular kids in high school
they're you know what I mean and you're
the nerd the Dork sitting there at the
lust table and you know whoever walks in
and they're like they're charming and
Everyone likes them and they're so
pretty and everyone just wants to be be
them or be with them that's the actors
are like that that's why we always point
the cameras at them you know because
they have that charm and they have that
look
so it can feel like you're the dork in
high school who's got to go up and now
you want me to talk to this person and
tell them what to do and they're gonna
listen that why would they listen to me
who am I so that's the feeling
oftentimes that you can get
well the reality is they're a person
and oftentimes I find that especially
when they can be difficult to work with
it's because they're terrified
they're they're just a person they
happen to be blessed with this beautiful
outer shell a lot of the time but that
doesn't mean they don't have
insecurities as well and the more
they're left on their own
without any direction the more insecure
they can feel I mean think about what
that must be like if you you go out
there and you do your scene and no one
says anything to you and you have just
bared your soul in some scene and no
one's going good job or whatever like
that that that might even frustrate you
make you angry well with good reason
right I mean it's like working for any
boss and the boss is never telling you
if you're doing good work
never encouraging you never to I mean it
would be very frustrating place to be so
understanding that they are just a human
and it's so funny because
oftentimes I'll come up
actor will come up on on set I'll walk
up to them and I can see them trembling
like
you're if I'm you know and it's weird
because I'll be at my director's chair
and talking to the DP and we're doing
this over here and I look and there's
the actor and they come in and oh
they're pretty and
and I'll walk up and I see him kind of
shaking it's like wow I never saw that
until I actually walked up and made that
connection so
the lesson there is I think really
making sure that they're recognized and
that they are um welcomed and feel safe
that is so important to do to because
what we're asking of an actor think
about this in the in the grand scheme of
a set
if you're a cinematographer they're not
they are operating a piece of Machinery
they're bringing their Artistry to it no
question they're creating emotion with
this camera painting with light but
they're not being vulnerable
they may be even if they are scared
you're never going to see it because
they're behind the lens you know
the same with the gaffer same with a
sound guy and a wardrobe person they I
mean if they're having a bad day they
could go and cry in their trailer you
know behind closed doors you never can
see that an actor they're they're naked
in front of the and everything that
you've been building for years with the
script and everything is pointing at
them the camera is pointing right that's
a lot of stress on a person so
when you see them walk in
you're in high school popular kid walks
in
can be the hardest thing to do to walk
up and just say hey how you doing
everything okay just to check in and
make sure they're all right that is a
huge move and that will be a
you think about it making them feel
welcome and comfortable even though it
looks like they may not need that do it
anyway that is a huge thing that will
help you
um
actors as well
simply and it sounds so simple to say
but they just want to know what you want
um
if you don't know
what you want
tell them
um
because
this is where you can invite them into
your own space in storytelling you can
say
this is a goodbye scene but I'm not sure
it needs to be a weepy one
you know and have a dialogue with them
about it because that's where the fun
can begin where you're actually going
you're saying goodbye to someone who
you've been best friends with for years
but they've always been mean to you
would you really be crying as you say
like what and you can start to play well
what if it's triumphant goodbye what if
it's and that's where it could be really
fun now you're going to start to see the
actor come alive because they are being
allowed to play with you and you know
you're on the same team that can really
be a lot of fun
um
I also think that
as a as a director
what we do because you know because
we've been thinking about this story for
longer than everybody else on the team
like they're longer than the DP the
Wardrobe person we've been in working
with the story forever
um and so it's very easy to and
necessary in a lot of ways to come in
with your own ideas about how the scene
should look and yes that's important but
um
you want to leave a little room for a
surprise you want to leave a little room
for them to bring what they have to the
table
and you would do that you do that in
every other department right you're
you're going to tell the DP
I just want this to look like
you know like the old films from the 70s
how they kind of had this Rich color
grain kind of looking for that kind of
Rich color grain in this kind of thing
and I'm thinking it's all shot on Long
lenses and the DP may go yeah but you
know in that time those kind of lenses
didn't exist they did a lot of zooms
instead of dollies so what if we did it
more zoomy lenses oh yeah that's right
that's right how cool is that that's you
creating together that's you allowing
the DP to kind of bring his Artistry or
her Artistry to the table do the same
with an actor I find it really enjoyable
process when they come to set
they've been working their lines by
themselves or with their
husband or wife or or sometimes even
just a recorder there they record it
they have a certain way if they want to
do the lines well let them try it
I think it's it can really create the
fun sandbox when you're you bring the
two or three actors and have everyone
pause the work let the DP sit over here
for a second and say all right let's
just walk through it a second and see
what's what you got
let me see what you got let's just let's
try it boom walk through the scene
um now they feel like they've
um brought something into the table
you're able to like okay that's cool
let's use this piece but I think what we
want to do is turn in this moment here
and then oh yeah yeah you know you're
now you're working together that really
allows them
a feeling like they've been heard
um
and that will just you could just you
can watch their anxiety just
go down
another big thing to remember with
actors is that when you're directing
this is super easy to do because you're
being hit with a thousand questions a
minute so
I mean it is
you just did a take the dp's like are
you sure it's okay with this lens like
this like I think maybe we go to a
tighter lens oh yeah okay good let's
swap to the 100 and do the blah blah
wardrobe person's like I don't know this
shirt looks kind of wrinkly and oh yeah
cool is that background prop looking
okay and you know everyone's asking and
the actor is standing there on their
mark
like is that all right like and you're
all right let's do it again you totally
forget that they're out there naked
wondering why we're doing it again and
it has nothing to do with them so
remembering
all right we need to do one more we got
to make a change on our end you're doing
just fine these keep doing that exactly
thing you're right in the right Zone but
we got to change something with the
camera we've hit a bobble on the cable
whatever it is like remembering that
it's like you're spinning plates on the
end of sticks and the actor is always on
the end out here and they you'd think
that they'd be the easiest one to
remember but that's the first one
usually most people forget is that
they're just standing out there on their
Mark you know waiting for someone to
talk to so just remembering to keep them
engaged I haven't forgotten about you
you're still there it's all good let's
fix something over here or whatever
um
I think
yeah that that happened a number of
times when they abandoned by the way
where it was the abandon is essentially
one actor in front of the camera the
whole time and a lot of these same rules
applied right so
the the premise of the abandon is a
soldier who's
hit with a bright light when he's in the
middle of a firefight and he wakes up in
this room with no doors windows exits of
any kind you can't get a hold of anybody
and the whole movie is him trying to
escape this mystery Room well that means
he's the only guy in front of the camera
the whole time that's an incredible
vulnerable place to be
the the actor that is like
it was his first lead in a movie
and
you know that's that's that's terrifying
I don't I wouldn't want that position
like if I were to lead in a film that's
scary enough but the fact that you're
the only face we're gonna see in this
whole movie oh my gosh
it was so important to take the time to
make sure he was okay
just a
greet him every day on set see check in
see how he was feeling you know making
sure he's comfortable go through it let
him try a couple takes to see what he
you know all of these same kinds of
things
and then with him specifically
there were a couple times where we would
have some bumps in the road and this
this leads me to a huge point
I made a couple mistakes
um there was a day where we were doing
some stunt sequences and and ironically
the moment I'm talking about is in the
trailer
there's a moment where the character
realizes that something is very wrong oh
no the big Discovery is being made and
he goes
we were trying to do this
very specific shot where the camera is
going to do this big Dolly push and it
it's tilting as it goes and he's leaning
on the wall a certain kind of way
and I'm
and the way the film is put together we
had this camera that could do this it's
called a Lambda head so we could tilt it
and and the film plays with gravity a
lot so we would always tilt the Lambda
head often times to make it look like
gravity was coming from the wrong
direction but when you look at the lens
and then you look at the stage it looks
ridiculous because the he's oftentimes
standing in a tilt and it's like I would
start chuckling because it's like I feel
like I'm making Star Trek in 1960
because it's just like people throwing
themselves around so I'm just like kind
of chuckling at the hilarity of it all
and I'm trying to get this very real
moment for him
the cinematographer wasn't feeling well
that day
and I'm trying to get this shot we were
all this is like three quarters away
through the shoot we're all completely
exhausted
and I'm giggling at the monitor well
here's the actor
all he knows is that people are looking
at him on screen and laughing
right so understandably so he was
feeling extremely insecure and got mad
at me it's a dude
I feel like my ass is hanging in the
wind out here you know
and I and I I guess I think you're
laughing at me and I realize in that
moment
that of course he would feel that way of
course he would think that he has no
idea the context of where I'm coming
from but the poor guy you know
is understandably frustrated with me so
the point I'm trying to make is these
things are going to happen you know
miscommunications happen
you're gonna snap sometimes you're gonna
say something that you didn't mean
that's gonna hurt somebody's feelings
and it's so important to own up to it to
you know after that day
I actually had to
we had a he and I had a long long talk
about like hey man
I never meant to humiliate you that is
was never my intent and I did not mean
for it to come out I was laughing at
something totally different just the
comical nature of what we do for a
living was really more of what I was
thought was so funny at the time
um it was nothing to do with how stupid
you looked it no I would never laugh at
something like that like I'm here to
protect you but I had to come forward it
was very difficult you know I had to
tell him and be very honest and really
protect him in that moment this happens
a lot you know if you find that you
snapped at your actor some way because
they
irritated you and you did it in front of
everybody it's a good idea to pull them
aside after that or the next day or
whatever and say hey
that was out of line
what that's going to do is
that's going to do this you're going to
be as vulnerable as there we're asking
them to be and it's going to put you on
this even level with them where you're
both hey we're human we're trying to do
this thing there's a lot of pressure the
Sun is going down we're running out of
time I snapped I'm sorry can we get past
this and just I'll try to do better next
time that's such a big
um
really I think important move to do to
be willing to do that uh that'll help
you with actors quite a bit
um
usually if you are that vulnerable with
them
their performance will go up because
they know that it's safe they know that
you're all working together trying to do
the same kind of thing and they once
they are vulnerable vulnerability with
an actor is the secret sauce to good
performance
because that is what this is why this is
what makes them different this is what
when you see Denzel Washington
performing what you're seeing that's so
incredible is he's so open
he's you are seeing the inner workings
the inner Terror the little soul in
there that's what's so interesting
that's what makes us all lean into the
screen that's that's what draws Us in
it's these it's these well people who
behave like that
generally become actors who are used to
exposing themselves like that
it's not normal that's not what normal
humans do that's what makes them so
interesting to watch that's what we need
but in order to see that you have to
make them feel safe feel comfortable
they want to see vulnerability in you
its relationship
why is it a bad decision to make a movie
with one actor and one location
why is it a bad decision
why is it bad to say you know
having one actor
in a movie with one location it's just
such a great idea on paper because you
read that and you're like wow this could
be so cheap to shoot
which is true it's true
now I will say in the case of our film
you know that is what it is it's one
actor in one location
and for the first several whatever weeks
when you're thinking about how cool it
would be to do that it's great but then
the realization starts to sink in that
huh I have nothing to cut to
what are you going to cut to when it's
one actor in our case you don't ever get
to see outside of the mystery Room to
see where he is that's hope this whole
mystery of the movie is where is he so
it becomes incredibly complex to figure
out how am I gonna
block this scene when it's one guy
on the phone the whole time
it becomes
far more complicated than you ever
thought possible because you're now you
have to figure out how to
capture scenes in a way that continues
to be interesting
changing up the camera angle keeping the
camera moving figuring out what the
moments are
that's really difficult to do and we
just really struggle with that this and
it also becomes a real problem because
in the editing room if there's a scene
that's dragging how are you going to cut
around that because
if your actor is walking around the room
uh
you can't exactly cut for time like if
the scene is five minutes too long and
he's doing a circle around the room
which we did a couple times
well if I cut five minutes out of the
scene suddenly he's on the other side of
the room he's on the wrong side of the
room so you're really stuck with that so
that was a big issue that I did not
anticipate going in and how difficult
that was going to be uh
what saved us on that front and if you
are shooting a project that you have one
subject in one very small location
insert shots is what's going to save
your life uh now for us if you can do
this it's great but for us we couldn't
do it you know cut to the exterior of
the house
sure it's nightfall or passage of time
or something we didn't have that option
we were in the box so we were stuck
um
and I found like he's on the phone so
like having
we had to come up with different ways of
him like sometimes he's got the phone
like this but then to take the phone and
have him put it on speakerphone and put
it on his chest helped sometimes he sets
it on the ground so we we had to be
really creative about how to um laughs
do it so that like so then if the
phone's on the ground and it's
speakerphone well now you can just get a
bunch of inserts of the phone here and
uh now we can up cut to time and cut
things out if we have to do it that
saved our butts
um the other real challenge when you
have one actor like that in one location
is that it can start to look visually
very boring
um
because one thing that we love about the
movies is especially is visual spectacle
and if it's one slap on the screen
talking the whole time it's like wow how
am I going to make that interesting so
that also was a real challenge for us is
how
how to keep this visually interesting
and one of the ways that we did that was
we continually messed with the light
we tried to make the room like another
character so we would actually show
shots of the room and then the room
would shift in the way that the lighting
was so it actually starts from Bright
you know we had where we had a very soft
overhead kind of light it goes to the
side it has more of a nightmarish
contrasty look and the light kept it
moved from overhead it started moving to
the side it kept getting lower and lower
and lower throughout the film until he
was with a flashlight and actually the
stuff worries with the flashlight is
what looks the best but it continues to
morph and change the look of your room
so that doesn't look same same same same
the whole time
that was something that I never never
considered moving in the other
real challenge is you really better have
a good set
um ours was a gray box
um and it looked good like I I thought
that the production did a really good
job but
man you know when you don't have any
furniture like
keeping something in the background that
looks good that's tough that was a
another significant challenge
which is why we decided to change up the
lights and and keep it looking different
we also um
change the lensing a lot too like we we
mapped out different beats
of the story and each
chunk
had a different name and look so we
would call it like this is the nightmare
beat so in the nightmare beat we shot
with these kinds of lenses with the
light looking this way and the framing
looked like this so that it constantly
morphed and changed because boy you will
you'll water torture your audience to
death if if you're not careful
um
so if you're yeah if you're doing a
movie like that where it's one character
one room
I would really spend some time thinking
about
how to continue to change the look
you know
there's a movie called buried which is
an excellent film with Ryan Gosling
where he's in a coffin the whole movie
and they did something really
fascinating with that movie where they
used
a cell phone for light
there's a cell phone a flashlight
a lighter
and green glow sticks so each of those
have a different color temperature so it
changes the feel of the room as the
movie goes that was very clever very
interesting way to keep it looking
different they also had a bunch of very
creative ways of filming
in a space like that it's a coffin you
know that's tough but they would build
long coffins they would build deep cop
and some some were bigger they would
also do really complex camera moves and
that's something we did as well we would
map out very complex
moves where the camera's going up and
down and left and right and the camera's
kind of dancing as opposed to sitting in
one location and the camera just
boringly pointing at them that'll kill
you if you don't you got to be very
careful um
your face with that so
we also I think the other thing that
really helped us was sound
and this is the constant thing I find is
overlooked in indie film is the
importance of sound and I'm not talking
about
mic sound I'm talking about sound design
we it helped the world feel bigger
by the way it sounded and adding weight
to this one room
and make it like how does a threatening
room sound now that will really it can
increase your production value
especially if it we made it sound like
there was other Machinery outside the
room
uh that that took a lot of work to do
but um without that
you know I didn't anticipate going in
how much work that was actually going to
be that took months and months and
months of I did a lot of the sound
design on it so
months of figuring out how
to create a room that feels like it's a
threat just auditorily you know
um yeah a lot of lessons learned on that
a lot of lessons learned and I
I think finally the last thing for us
we had another character on the phone
phone conversations are really
interesting to shoot
because it is it's exactly it's one
actor
blah blah and you can't see that if
you're not shooting the other end of the
conversation it's just what's on their
face
well there's a number of ways to do that
I think a lot of times they'll have
someone off camera reading the lines to
them who's not an actor now that is a
often I know I get for convenience
that's often times what happens but it's
really doesn't do the actor any favors I
was really worried about that with ours
with our film because
our actor really needed to be vulnerable
and terrified and if we had some
scripty
are you scared in the room I'm scared
you know like it's not gonna work how's
an actor supposed to get in the
character when you're the person reading
the script is just some person who's
just there drinking their coffee and in
their Ugg boots like that's just not
gonna work so I had the actor on set the
other actors on set we actually built
her her own little off stage box of her
own because she's in our story she says
in is claiming to be in a similar space
so we we tried to make her feel just
like that what that did was it it put
them both in a vulnerable position and
now they can hear each other actually on
set as opposed to just over the over the
phone and they were able to actually
physically connect and talk and work the
scenes out together that was a huge help
to us and also allowed for improvisation
um each of them had their own mics and
so now they're able to explore the scene
together and that helped us a ton
a ton
so if yeah if you're doing a project
like that I would highly recommend
exploring some of those options
um
and if it's one character on screen
really paying attention to how difficult
it's going to be for them to do it
the kind of
uh accommodations you're going to have
to do to make them comfortable because
that's that's becomes what it's all
about
because they're the only one you're
going to see
and so then are you dealing with almost
two arcs because you have the Arc of the
main character but then you have the Arc
of the relationship yeah so now you're
working with kind of two you have the
beginning I mean not I don't want to
give away too much and and and but but I
really felt that that they were
connected and that they had a bond yeah
[Music]
um
without again giving but yeah I was
impressed that their conversations with
each other yeah that's exactly right
that there is an arc in the course of
our story there is I mean as all stories
should have an arc with characters now
what's interesting about the behind the
scenes of that
so the two actors didn't really know
each other before this whole thing began
they kind of met each other very quickly
before the start of filming so there
really was no relationship
in the course of filming
my relationship with both of them was
really key so
oftentimes this is going to sound really
dorky but oftentimes you know at the
beginning of a shot and it's him alone
in this big room especially when we're
doing the early reveals and the
terrified look I'd hold his hand
you know before with as the camera's
getting all right every real camera real
sound I ain't quite unsaid I don't know
take lunch and I just stay there with
him like let them know you're not alone
I'm right here got you got you all right
you ready ready to do this yeah right
right and then I'll back off and then
let him do the scene
that
um eased off as we as we went and as she
slowly became part of his world because
the two characters meet essentially on
the phone and they get to know each
other as the story grows
she essentially came in and replaced me
so I was able to back away slightly as
the Director and then she was able to
come in and oftentimes would hold his
hand during scenes especially when there
was emotional scenes or and I would like
try things with them
because it was all about the connection
even though it's only on the phone but I
would say things like
um
tell each other a secret
that none of us can hear like well I'll
turn the mics off and just tell each
other something that no one else knows
and it's such an interesting place to be
Associated as a director because you see
them say something and then they start
laughing or something like that and it's
like what did they what'd you say
it's not for me to know like that's only
between them that's something that the
two of them can share but that really
went
and and uh pulled them together and then
as the scenes went oftentimes I would
let them just improv and I would tell
her you know what do you really want to
ask him
what do you really want to know and
she'd go yeah boom and she and we'd be
recording and just boom she'd just go
right into something and try stuff that
was such an interesting you know we were
all kind of crossing paths and I'm
pulling away while she's coming it was
it was a very
um
very cool spot to be
what are the steps to developing and
building a character
yeah developing characters so that's
I think some people have a easier time
with that than others so
I learned this from uh actually I guess
that you had a on yours uh show Corey
Mandel like where he he actually in one
of his interviews ironically said
that there are generally as a general
rule two kinds of writers there are
intuitive writers who see characters
very clearly in three dimensions and
they just bleed on the page and that
kind of thing and then there are more
conceptual writers who are very good at
the structure part uh personally I'm
gravitate more towards the intuitive
side so like and this comes as a
director because uh when I'm working
with actors I can very quickly pivot
into deep backstories and things like
that so for me how do I create
characters it it's a little bit of an
easier task for me but there is a
process that I generally go through
that
starts with me asking like some
questions like
what is
the one thing my character would never
do that's an interesting question to ask
about a character but it can tell you a
lot about who they are so
what would my character never do well
they would never I don't know quit
whatever would never quit Okay well that
that automatically that question can
open up a huge Rich story about why
wouldn't they ever what is it about
quitting that's so pivotal to their core
you can also ask and I'll do this what
is one thing they would never say
they may never say I hate you
or whatever uh
now of course you know in the
storytelling realm you would now have to
make them do those things now you know
and of course what would they never say
they would never say I hate you well why
wouldn't they ever say that like what is
it about that word that means so much to
them that they would never actually say
I hate you to another person
it's a way of unlocking
um certain kinds of things
so
that's usually the first step in in that
and then
coming up with what is your character's
major Focus not just as a as a story but
in their life what is it that they are
aiming for
overall like for example I'm working on
a pilot right now and
I'm doing a lot of work on realizing
what is this main character's
drive and this is he's an interesting
one because his Drive is to escape his
past
right because it's he had a very abusive
past and um
and he is pushing and driving and
running he's an ex adrenaline junkie
he's like pushing the edge all the time
looking for the next thrill
his
Drive isn't the next thrill his Drive is
to escape so just going through and
understanding what that is really also
tells you a lot
um
so that's usually where it begins for me
I'll do this little checklist and then
what I like to do
in my perfect designing world all you
know I'm a morning Time Rider so I'll
get up and do my morning routine I'll
take my little hourglass and I'll flip
it upside down I'll start the hour clock
turn off the phone and I'll start brain
dumping I really like the process of
just like
uh just furiously letting my keys go on
the keyboard or notebook two it's a
different method but it's sometimes fun
to just like explore who they are what
if uh
Izzy is just someone who just never
could quite find the right one just
she just tossed and turned her whole
life and just started exploring
um the path as it were of this character
and just digging into their lives and
never correcting anything but just like
going down and even as I'm writing she's
someone that I can never find love no
that doesn't feel quite right
she's someone that did find Love She
Found Love early on but he you know he
ended up leaving her for someone else
and now she's kind of like you know what
I mean like it's this it's complete
immersive exploration into my character
and there's no judgment there's no wrong
stories uh wrong choices here I can
actually go back and edit in real time
but I don't erase anything that's on the
page I just put it all down there
there's something very therapeutic and
really fun in the play of that
um
I like to
I will in life
um as I
I could be at the grocery store and I'll
hear an interesting conversation
um like here's a perfect example I was
at a sandwich shop one time and
I'm ordering a sandwich and the guy's
like so you know what do you want I'm
like uh you know maybe I'll take the BLT
okay cool what kind of bread do you want
and I'm looking at all the Breads and
it's this really good Bakery it's just
very it's a great sandwich shop and I'm
going um
well you got a bunch of different kinds
of breads here I've never I don't even
recognized what do you recommend and he
goes oh all our breader made right here
in the shop like you there is no wrong
choice I said oh so you're a sandwich
agnostic then
and he goes
you know who wasn't an agnostic and I
thought oh no oh no no no no don't say
it don't say it he goes
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
and it was so funny to me that he would
say like he just basically took my joke
that I thought was kind of funny and
just
flustered down the toilet because
clearly This Guy's super super religious
well there's a great character for his
story someone who is so religious that
they just that everything it diffuses
the fun out of everything
I I have a little note I use a Evernote
in on my phone and I'll like write that
stuff down I'm like oh that's an
interesting character or they I used to
know another guy who would always
whistle and the more stressful things
God he would always
[Music]
that's such a great little Quirk so I
will keep track of these things and as
I'm exploring what the character can do
when it comes to quirks and things
sometimes I'll look through all this
list of things and go oh yeah this one
would really fit let me
carve this into this person
um
it's helpful too to like
take in the whole person like what how
tall are they how big are they
um
are they are they a ginger or are they
bald or are they you know like just to
really kind of be have fun with
and and sometimes that involves like um
just doing random Google searches or
even Instagram like how you can on
Instagram you can hit the little
magnifying glass thing and it'll just
pop up this random feed of things
you'll be scrolling through and
sometimes you'll see just someone with
the most interesting look they'll have
glasses with a really thick black frames
and their hair is a certain way and they
have black fingernails oh there's an
interesting looking person so that's a
really helpful way it's just like
cataloging all these different people
types that are out there and random
quirks that's super helpful when it
comes to creating characters
um
as it goes and as it develops
what I'll need to do is I I really like
knowing their internet cores their inner
what makes them tick what do they
believe what do they
going back to the what do they struggle
with where are they going in life
um
I like to get more specific about that
as I develop them in the story that kind
of thing but that's generally the
process I know it's not a one two three
step but that's that's usually what I'll
do
do with that as I go is there a
fictional character that you know you
talked about earlier that one movie that
we all see that if we come here to La
that we've like I wanna I should have
been part of that and that's what I want
to recreate is there a character or two
where you felt that like that's the
character I don't care if I'm playing it
or filming it or writing it that's the
character
well I can think of a movie that really
hit me you know a closing count as a
Third Kind was one that really just blew
my imagination
um
the
especially the little kid when he's
because I was really little when that
movie was out but the the little kid who
was searching for UFOs like boy I really
identified with that
that one and and ironically around the
same time was when the first Star Wars
came out and Empire
I always saw myself as C-3PO I that's
such a strange one like no one
identifies as C3 video but because my
brother was shorter than me and he was
always the annoying little brother like
he was R2D2 and I was C3PO so like
they're such unique characters that's
what they're little
um
antagonistic connection
very much reminded me of me and my
brother and I I sort of loved loved that
uh
and the idea of figuring out how to
create that was really really fun as
especially as a kid to think about that
uh
yeah
Indiana Jones is another one that
he's such a cool character and how do
you make that and
that would definitely be one as a kid I
was definitely like
anything to be a part of the creation of
a process like that you know
the man of Adventure and and ah so good
with the comedic stuff and ah it's so
good it's so good it's so good just yeah
would you rather make a story about good
versus evil or good versus good
I Pro I think probably good versus evil
that's always a it's just such a fun
I mean my initial gut reaction is making
a story of good versus evil
I mean that is that's like so steeped in
our society as humans I mean you know
Warring with the gods you know way back
in the day those are the stories we were
coming up with so I think that's just
ingrained in our culture excuse me grain
in our culture
um
so I immediately gravitate towards that
and when I think of stories of good
versus evil they always sound epic it's
like making these big fantasy epics is
very exciting
but that said good versus good
is something that's more
um
fascinating from a character perspective
and I think it's more challenging to
write stuff like that you know good
versus evil is a lot easier to write
because it's the villain who wants to
take over world domination or something
like that you know that's an easy thing
to go up against but if it's a good
versus good
I want custody for the of the kids
husband and wife getting divorced
they're both good people each one wants
the child and they're both good people
that's much more that is very
interesting to write it's very
it requires a lot more of you I think as
a Storyteller to actually pull a story
like that off because
now you're trying to put the audience in
a position of
which one do I root for
that's really a challenge that it's
in a great way
I still think I would normally gravitate
towards good versus evil because it's
just so great you know you know to fight
the villain or Darth Vader or whatever
it is
ironically
Darth Vader becomes a good guy at the
end but uh uh that I I tend to gravitate
to our stories more like that but I
think as I get older I do like more of
the nuanced
um
complex human conflicts you know it just
requires more of you to write it it's
more of a challenge you talked about
good versus good well you could say
Kramer versus Kramer yep that was good
versus good and that was an extremely
compelling film yeah and and difficult
to watch and and want to root for I
don't know either side but in terms of
um good versus evil it seems like the
quote-unquote evil always thinks that
they're good yeah so it could initially
be a story of you know someone who
thinks they're actually doing the right
thing it's true and um which those kinds
of stories if you're making good versus
evil it
it is the
back for about lack of a better term the
lazier riding approach to just make them
evil for the sake of being evil that is
a
I guess you can make it easier to hate
or whatever they're just villains for
the sake you see bad action movies like
this well bad movies in general are like
this but
I mean any writing class will tell you
that that's not the best way to make a
villain it's much better when they
because think of it in life no one
actually thinks they're evil nope I
don't even think Hitler thought Hitler
actually thought he was doing the world
of favor right so
if you want to make it compelling
I mean I just my previous
feature before abandon was about angels
and demons
and we wrote all the demons in a way
that they actually thought they were
doing
good
so that was a very interesting writing
challenge to how you make something as
evil as that
justified in their actions how do they
actually justify what they do it it
really pushes you
um
and it makes it it pulls you in a lot
more as an audience I think uh
it Demands a lot more maturity from you
as the artist
because you can because think about from
the actor perspective too instead of
this mustache twirling you know if you
go to the actor and say I want you to be
the mustache twirling villain
versus
I want you to
they're trying to take away your home
that's how you see this uh
you'll see such a much deeper
performance from your actor that will in
the end be more terrifying
um I've had
moments with actors where
I will tell them
protect you're you're doing something
really heinous here but you're doing it
because you're personally offended by
what they did to you like it actually
hurts you it makes you even sad and
you'll have the and they'll do this
performance almost With Tears in their
eyes but it makes it so much more
terrifying because
you could tell how deeply they feel oh
love that I love that so is that good
versus good I don't know
it depends on the perspective of the uh
character I guess you know
but it's definitely a much more
I answered your question and now I'm
changing my mind as I'm answering it
because I think that a good versus good
if you if you look at it from the
perspective of the character
that's what the best stories are
Up For Debate yes Up For Debate leave
your comments below
[Laughter]
how do you write a great scene
I'd agree you know riding a great scene
is
is it one of the
strangely hardest things you can do as I
think the writing piece of all the stuff
we have to do in filmmaking is the
hardest part that because that's where
it all begins that's the foundation that
your entire house is built on
and when you're building this house
the easiest thing to do
is you get your house done and you're
looking at it
and you're like
something looks off it doesn't look over
level and you'll get notes and they'll
the notes will come back and say yep
it's probably because your house is red
if you paint it green it might not look
off so you'll paint it green and it's
still off but it's because the
foundation isn't right
and the foundation of scene work is is
really
amazingly hard to do amazingly hard to
do
um
what I've learned especially over the
last few years in depth is
how tricky it is to come up with scenes
that work and I think the best way you
can learn this is through watching plays
plays now every not every filmmaker but
a lot of the filmmakers I talk to they
always say I just can't write small I
just can't write simple
uh
I get that because oh I want to go into
outer space and fly ship around and I
want to plant it to explode well that's
great I do too but what that can be
it can be the filmmaker waving their
arms in front of the camera saying I
don't have a story so I'm going to
distract you with all of these
explosions so that you forget the fact
that weather actually really isn't a
very good foundation and the whole house
is still leading to the left because you
never figured out how to write a good
scene
it comes down to these very simple nuts
and bolts so if you watch a play you're
watching scenes on the most basic level
and you're looking at generally one or
two characters or two or five characters
or something talking
on a stage
and you're pulled in
how are they doing that what is the
magic sauce that's making all that that
scene work
it reminds me of and I think that those
filmmakers myself included if they want
to get better at this don't start by
making scenes with explosions start by
making scenes that are simple two people
in one room this is I had a friend of
mine that used to teach like a summer
camp for drummer like a music I work in
a musicians Camp he was a drummer he
would teach all the drummer kids and he
said the first thing he would always do
on day one is all the kids would come in
with all their drum sets and they would
set up these elaborate you know multiple
Toms and snares and this big giant sets
he would let them get all set up and
then he'd go okay
I want you to take apart your drum sets
and only give yourself one kick one
snare and one symbol
and the kids panicked because they
suddenly all their tools were taken from
them
and they had to learn how to get good at
making music with just the kick snare
and
that's tough anybody can sound great
with two kick drums but do it with just
those three little symbols same with
scene work
so how do you make a good scene work
well
it's so simple
yet it seems to be lost on a vast
majority of people
you have to be
the number one thing I think when it
comes to scene work is Clarity of goals
and Stakes
Clarity that means knowing exactly I
just had a um it's so interesting I just
had a script consultant take a look at
one of my scripts
he said to me
because what do you think you're best at
in your writing I said I think I'm
pretty good at writing action when
people read my scripts they say
um
the action is like usually really
compelling and like
he goes what do you think you struggle
with the most I said well you know
probably like the all the things in
between the little connector pieces and
the overarching like sometimes scene
work and stuff like that like exactly
what I'm talking about he goes you know
why you know why they say that like no I
don't because because in action scenes
it's very clear what the character wants
they're trying to win the motorcycle
race or whatever right so it's super
easy to write this compelling action
scene because I gotta get over the
Finish Line before the other guy does
very clear goal very clear stake I don't
want to lose the race so it's a it's a
really compelling scene he goes that's
why your action scenes are selling
better it's not because you're magical
with words it's because me as an
audience member understands what he
wants one is just husband and wife
talking about getting going shopping
it's just like because there's just
nothing there so
this is
super common and then we hear to make
all this more difficult we we are told
I don't know who tells us this I don't
know where this comes from but
um
on the nose writing right is considered
bad writing well what what
why is that
considered bad writing have you ever
wondered that why who I don't know who
initially said this but on on they say
that on the nose writing and when I say
on the nose I mean Clarity what does
your character want and where is he
going what and what is at stake if he
doesn't get it
well in order to understand what that is
that means being on the nose and very
clear I really want to get out of this
house okay
but we're told we're there's somehow in
our filmmaking Society we're told that
on the nose writing is bad well why is
that why why who who initially said that
that was a thing
I'm not sure who said it but in some
ways it doesn't let the audience really
guess and the relationship unfold it's
too it's just there's no mystery to it
you need subtext right yes we we want
this man we want it to be
um we are we want we want to be so
clever about
and making them figure it out right
well
the thing is
that's and I and I totally get that
because I'm totally wired the same way
like I don't I want to be
more clever about the way to reveal what
the character wants
but on the nose writing what makes it
that is is it almost makes it feel that
way because when you see well done
scenes when you see a scene that just
wraps you in and pulls you right along
the writing is pretty on the nose
but
they are essentially giving us
what makes things feel on the nose is
when I'll give you an example you know
you see an action like a bad action
movie and at the very beginning of the
action movie usually there's a scene
like
we got to go in and kill that guy
because he killed my sister and I'm
going to take revenge on the blah blah
and it's just long drawn out like setup
of
okay we gotta go kill the bad guy
because he killed my sister and
it it feels really clunky and on the
nose the reason why is because we didn't
ask for that information that's what
makes us feel on the nose as an audience
member you're like you're handing me all
of this stuff I didn't need
but
if you hand it to me in a way
that makes me go what is his name
then reveal it it's on the nose but it's
when I ask for it well what is it about
this guy that bothers him what grievance
did this villain do that makes it so bad
uh
killed his sister you're revealing it at
the right time that is a real trick when
it comes to
putting a scene together properly but
where it starts is it starts with
I think
not
writing in final draft it starts with
very clear outlines and mapping
what you want so
and this is where
there's a simple goal and stake so what
I mean by that if you don't know what
that means that means like
I want to get out of the house
but the thing that's often missed is
what are the stakes of that what happens
if he doesn't
get that or she right what happens if I
don't get out of the house well if it's
just I'm gonna be bored well it's going
to be really hard for me to get behind
that as a story
you have to come up with a way to make
that
so terrifying if they don't actually get
there
um if the house is on fire
I'm gonna get third degree burns if I
don't get out of the house now that
Stakes
you know if the house has ghosts in it
you know now there's a reason to get out
of the hat like that you're you're tying
Stakes to it
um
but that's just the beginning because
you also need
someone against those
stakes and goals usually with their own
stakes and goals attached to them and if
you really want to make a scene work
you've got to come up with a way to put
those two things against each other
so I want to get out of the house
but character B wants me to go upstairs
that's a conflict
and if me going upstairs means I'm just
I'm thinking off the cuff here but like
if I want to get out of the house
because
I don't know why I'm going so dark with
this but if there's a demon that's
trying to take my soul
right so okay let's just say that's the
story there's a demon that wants to take
my soul and he's ah and I gotta get out
of the house well that's huge steaks oh
my gosh
character B walks in and says I need you
to go upstairs okay so so now for me
like that's a huge deal there's no way
I'm doing it
but for them okay let's imagine there's
a bigger threat outside that the outside
person sees like maybe there are zombies
outside and if you go outside you're
going to die so we need everyone to go
upstairs
now you have a conflict so that's a
scene that's that's two characters that
have two different goals and they're
they're running into each other I need
to get out of the house the other one's
going no you need to go upstairs well if
I stay in the house my soul is gonna be
taken by this demon but if you go
outside you're going to get eaten by the
zombies well if someone's gonna someone
needs should win right that's what makes
it compelling conflict now I went way
monster movie to horror movie or
whatever with that idea but that is
essentially the essence of what makes a
great scene taking two characters that
each have differing goals and aligning
them so that they are hitting each other
um
probably a better example would be
someone needs to get into the
um bank vault
right I need to get in there okay I'm
writing the scene I need to come up with
a way
that's my goal I have to get in the bank
vault and I don't know get my marriage
certificate out of the
that's the I am a marriage certificate I
need to go in there and I need to get it
I'm all in one with a key
you know how it works safety positive
safe deposit box my marriage
certificates in there I got the key it's
handcuffed to my wrist I have to be the
one to go in and unlock it and of course
you've got to have the other usually
there's two people that unlocks the
thing together you know how it works at
the bank let's say that's your goal okay
that makes sense
well how am I how do I make this goal
exciting
well we need to create someone with
opposition
all right but we can put a security
guard there now I think most people when
they would write a scene like that we
could make a security guard there that
doesn't want to let them in
okay so the security guard's there he
doesn't want to let them in the room
and you could just
oh he just lays him he doesn't want to
get off his chair and open the door I
think
does that do you would you think that
that is a scene that could work and they
be getting this argument about how he's
just lazy and he just
likes his chair he just
wants to stay there do you think that
would be a scene that would work
only if I discover later that actually
he's part of a larger ring that's stolen
these marriage certificates and he's
selling them on the dark web
true so if you see yeah he seems lazy
and he seems innocent enough but
actually no because your certificate is
actually not in there anymore oh that's
interesting okay
and he doesn't want you to know that
so I guess if he's just lazy uh I need a
good reason why he's lazy yeah right
okay so a lot of times you'll see scenes
like this where it's like I need to get
in there to get my thing out of the
drawer well and the other person just
doesn't want to do it well and then they
break into this argument so
this is very common you'll see this kind
of scene all the time and as two people
in this argument
but what's missing there are Stakes for
both of them number one and the security
guard has no goal
like he's not really he's just
resistance he's not
he's not an antagonist necessarily so
what that's doing is it's diffusing your
scene it's going to help drag it down
instead what you could do is you could
make a scenario where the security guard
has an extremely jealous wife who thinks
he's cheating on her and he and she
think you know he's supposed to stay at
his desk and just like let people into
the room
you know he tells her over and over I
got to go in there and unlock both doors
no I swear you when all the pretty girls
show up you go inside and you go in
there with him because you want to flirt
and you go in there with one more girl
and I'm Gonna Leave You and I'm gonna
sit here in the lobby and watch and make
sure that you don't now you gotta
conflict he's sitting there going I
can't open I can't let you in there I
can't do it or my wife is going to leave
me and and the other character is now
getting in now you have two characters
with two separate goals that are
slamming into each other this is very
very
um it sounds so simple to do but this is
where it's important to like really
outline and put on a I like putting on a
big white board
you know your directions that your
characters are going and make them go
into each other and then more
importantly attach Stakes to each one of
them if I don't get into that safe
deposit box to get the
whatever
marriage certificate if I don't get that
I can't prove that I was
I'll lose my inheritance if I can't show
that I whatever
okay
now you have steaks and then you put the
security guard where his marriage is
going to fall apart if he lets you in
great
you can almost feel the tension go up
you can feel it on set too when you have
a scene that has these kinds of things
attached to it the actors relish it like
they can immediately you feel it come
alive you can feel it right how you can
just suddenly the tension goes up you
haven't even started working on
escalations and how you you suddenly amp
up the tension in a scene like that or
adding and Ticking you know
it's 459 and it closes at five we
haven't even gotten there yet it's just
two characters with goals now it gets a
lot easier to to really make a scene
work that's where it always begins
that's that's the initial building box
did you see uh come back to the five and
dime Jimmy Dean Robert Altman it's based
on a play it's from 1982 or something so
it's just one room it's a Woolworth in
like Marfa Texas
and all the characters it's all women
except for one man and he's in and out
it's kind of a memory and the just the
subtleties that it's not on the nose but
you learn about the characters then you
learn about their Petty gripes and
jealousies with one another you learn
about the small town gossip all of it is
slowly revealed until the real story
finally comes out but it it's so
excellent and you're just there riveted
and it's one location
yeah writing scenes in one location is
especially simple ones with just
character driven with no fancy tricks it
is the most challenging thing but I do
believe that that's where all scenes
should begin
no matter if they're in space or some
sci-fi time travel epic or not because
that's a foundation
right now if you never go into outer
space or back in time and you stay in
the room with the Woolworths
you don't have any way to wave your
hands around to distract the audience
that you have nothing does that make
sense like so
I think that if you really want to
create more complex sci-fi stories you
need to really get good really good at
writing those simple
start writing scenes with two characters
each of them has something that they
want only one of them can win
both of them can lose write a scene like
that that's a page Turner and you're
going to be amazing at riding the Big
Space Opera like
it's hard to do but it's that's so if
you want to make it as a screenwriter
that's you have to master that
how hard is it to write an emotional
scene
for me personally well I should say for
me personally it's
not as hard and I only say that because
I tend to be very intuitive in my
writing process and a lot of times when
I'm writing I'm feeling it a lot more
than other people are
um
that as an intuitive kind of person I
just have very deep emotions and they
just come out really easily and there's
very easy to spill it on the page
but the challenge for me is actually
getting the audience to feel the same
way
so
on I'm about to say unfortunately
it comes down to structure it's really
if you really want to pull out emotion
it's it has less to do with
depth as it has to do with
the structure of your scene because the
structures what's gonna
the structure is your frame of your
house but the emotion is the furniture
within it so without that structure of
the house you're just gonna have
furniture sitting in the middle of a
field it's just gonna feel weird it's
gonna even if the actor's bringing it
it's still going to be kind of in this
weird nebulous space it's not really
much of anything but with the structure
it's what contains everything it's super
vital it get back gets back to the same
kind of stuff we were just talking about
about the importance of goals and stakes
and all kinds of things like that like
if you wanna
I could I could very easily
write out an emotional scene about
someone who lost their father like
you know you could have someone oh I
miss dad and he passed away you know
and if you just tuned in and watched the
one scene and the actress does a great
performance you know pulling that out
yeah it might be compelling
but it's not going to have the impact
that you that you want it to have unless
you understand more about why dad's loss
was so important right where
what that relationship was like that's
all that's all the structure of
backstory and context that you need to
set up so that when we get to emotional
scene it it's paying off in the way that
you mean for it to
otherwise it's just one character
spouting off and just kind of being
emotional
um you know Denzel Washington could pull
that off but
even then if it doesn't have
forward direction to it
um
it's just not gonna land the way you
hope and this happens a lot as in my
personal Journey as a screenwriter where
I'm just like so feeling these scenes
that I've written and then other people
read and go yeah this wasn't
quite planning ah it's so yeah what the
guy's pouring his heart out on paper
yeah it's because there's the guy's all
he's doing is pouring his hot art on
paper without going anywhere he's just
wallowing and there's no point there's
no direction there's there's
do you know it's so much more you know
in the movie Breaking Bad or a movie the
pilot episode of Breaking Bad
there's a fantastic scene in there
where Walter White if you've seen this
show he he starts off as this very
vanilla
spineless guy
and you watch him take this journey
where you learn that he's got cancer
he's gonna die he realizes his life is
over he realizes he's got no savings to
save his family
and then through all this he's realizing
you know he's a chemistry teacher and he
knows about science and all this stuff
um
and he sees that criminals who sell math
make a lot of money and he sees oh
there's a way for me to make a lot of
money right
so he's watching his journey going
through all these steps
and there's this great scene right after
he's bought all the equipment he's
decided he's going to cook meth
and he's this very introverted character
and Jesse comes up to him and says
you know this isn't how I remember you
at all like like at all like you you
were this kind of douche like the just
this lame teacher that just didn't seem
like he cared about anything and all of
a sudden you just have this passion
what is it what happened
and I think the performance of the scene
was very powerful
Walter White looks at him he says I'm
awake it's so simple but it carries so
much of a punch because you had all of
this really good setup framework of his
life and you watch how his life is like
teak things are falling apart he's dying
he's not going to leave anything in this
world and you see him wake up and it
carries the emotional impact because we
saw it we experienced it all with him
and then boom you're hit with it around
that scene I I that's what makes
emotional scenes work now
is it easy to do I don't think it's easy
to do I think it takes a lot of practice
and hard work
but
now if someone else could do all that
work for me and set all that up and then
write in the emotional scene by itself
it's super easy
for me because I think that way but um
yeah the challenge is is all the context
so an emotional scene
where you're just like bleeding in front
of the audience doesn't work unless
there's a setup I mean it could work I
just don't think it's it's not going to
carry the same punch that you want it to
unless they know
why they're feeling this way
why this is such a big moment if I mean
and think of it like if if there is a
character that you're following in a
movie or show and all they do is that
they're constantly emotional it's just a
late it's a chore to watch you don't
want to see it it's too much have you
ever seen a movie that's just so sad and
such a drag that you don't actually want
to watch it again
um that's the kind of feeling you're
gonna get you kind of need the journey
you need the setup you need the context
you need the goal the stakes and all
that to so that once that character does
get to that emotional break
you're in your you want you're on the
journey right with them
so yes it could be powerful on its own
and those are the odd the clips we see
from the Oscars
the best you know first nominee for
Academy Award is Jared Leto and you see
the emotional scene
uh
that's fine for a minute but it's not
going to carry the punch unless you see
the hole thing I don't think did you
watch the Queen's Gambit yeah excellent
did you like it yes very much and this
what I've took from that is that her her
circumstances were showing us this build
up but did she really have any full did
she ever feel sorry for herself I felt
like she didn't and she just turned it
all into the chess matches that's where
she took any type of self-pity or
whatever was beating you know whoever it
was that she wanted to be
that's a good point that's a good point
it's I actually think it's hard to watch
shows where characters feel sorry for
themselves
you know it's
they're out there I can't think of one
an example top my head but I think it's
hard
ER to watch you want to see a character
take their terrible background and turn
it into something make it their power
that's what that's exciting to watch
like the Queen's Gambit this little girl
raised an orphan suddenly becomes a
chess genius oh I'm him you know like
that's awesome like because she she's
the it's a classic Underdog Story sure
if uh you know if Rocky all did nothing
but whine about his poor background and
how he never got a chance as a boxer and
that's the end it would be hard to watch
but you know he he goes the distance
with Apollo Creed and we're like yeah
so yeah
what was one of the first films to make
you cry oh
you know I asked what the first film
that made me cry
I tell you the one that had the biggest
impact on me this is such a weird one
but it was The Prince of Tides I don't
know if you've ever seen that film but
it is a gut wrencher I'm sure that I got
emotional in films
prior to that but that one for some
reason really stands out because it
deals with the sky kind of
coming to terms with his very very
um tragic past
and I will say that
for me
emotions were always very much a
struggle because
they I always looked at them as
something that was weak
which is a problem for a director you
know and someone who tells stories in my
household growing up showing the showing
of vulnerability and emotion was
dangerous it's just not something that
you could do
um
and at and I do remember as I watched
films getting pulled in emotionally
whether it was
sadness tears
or Terror those two deep vulnerability
things
were stuff that I tried not to show and
tried very hard to fight it's part of
what made me a filmmaker because when I
would feel terrified or really sad I
would pull myself out and look at the
way the film was constructed
started looking at oh let me oh it's
just an actor sitting there and there's
a director talking to them and oh look
at the interesting lighting you know I
would purposely start to deconstruct the
film to pull myself out of the entire
experience
um
it took me many many years to really
become comfortable with just my own
emotions
I don't know why Prince of Tides
stands if you've ever seen that film
it's a fairy it's Barbra Streisand and
Nick Nolte and he's this kind of big man
and he's
uh he ends up like just sobbing and
breaking down that film really hit me
hard because I think it was very similar
to my own life that's probably why it
stands out to me so much it's one that
just boom but
emotions
are very key to the the business that
we're in and I think it's really
important to be comfortable with that
especially as a director because
I need to be I'm asking actors to do
that
and I want to be pulled in by that right
I'm asking audiences to be pulled in by
those same emotions well then what am I
doing trying to fight it all the time
and act like I don't feel anything
I maybe I'm in the wrong business if
that's how I'm approaching all of this
learning how to be okay with expressing
emotions I mean
it's taken me a long time but I've
gotten to a point now where I can be on
set talking to an actor and they're just
dumping out you know how they feel and
it's very they're in this very broken
place we're trying to capture that
and I am with them because I want to
show them it's okay so I oftentimes will
be
crying with them so sometimes that will
happen
but I'm also trying to talk to my DP
and the Wardrobe person in between all
of this so I have to be comfortable
enough while I'm in this kind of broken
spot with them to turn to my DP while
I'm
all right so let's grab the 85 and then
when we go on this moment but like not
be for years and years and years I
struggled with that
um position of like ah they're gonna
think I'm ugh what a wuss I had to like
really learn to let that go
um
it helps the entire room when you can
embrace it and just be okay with it it
will I feel like it will be imprinted on
the DNA of the film if you're okay with
it it'll help pull the audience in too
uh
some people are much easier with that
than others I I struggle with it for
many many years um but uh
yeah so Prince of time it's a tough
watch okay I'll have to go back and look
at that
so it's an obscure one it's funny that
that's the one that pops into my mind is
the first
but yeah I remember watching that one
it's like
oh it's it's a good movie directed by
Barbra Streisand
and she's in it with Nick Nolte yeah wow
yeah how many movies can you name off
the top of your head that if you saw
them today
they would make you cry
oh boy okay off the top of my head
it's gonna sound so funny Jaws and I
tell you why Jaws in the scene when the
little boy is mimicking his dad you know
what I'm talking about where he's he's
having a tough day and uh
and he's just sitting there thinking and
the other boys at the table and he's
like imitating his father and
uh he he realizes his son is copying him
and they're going back and forth doing
all these it's just it's just a
beautiful moment and in the end Roy
Scheider leans over to the boy and says
give me a kiss and the kid goes why
because because I need it ah that scene
gets me every time
um you know and I think it's that
definitely like father-son scenes like
the second Guardians of the Galaxy movie
when he wasn't he may have been your
daddy but he may have been your father
but he wasn't your daddy yandu no oh I'm
just a mess anything that deals with
Father and Son coming together and
having this body usually really gets me
um
I uh who off the top of my head
oh man I'm gonna think of it like as
soon as the camera stops and be like oh
this one and this one and this one and
this one
um
I just watched coded that one got me
that was if you're familiar with it it
stands for children of deaf adults and
it's about a deaf family
and the daughter is can hear the rest of
the family cannot and she wants to do
music It's A Beautiful film Beautiful
film Emily gets me quite a bit it's just
this beautiful love story about her
finding love and it's just so it's just
such a wonderful film um
I'm sure I'll be able to think more
later but yeah yeah
and I get more comfortable with it as I
get older of just like being vulnerable
to a lot of that stuff but yeah
does a director automatically deserve
respect
no
I mean you know I think that the
director automatically wants respect
but they don't necessarily deserve it I
think
and when you see frustration from
directors is because they don't have any
respect and people are just walking all
over him that usually comes from a
director that is
not prepared or not
uh not prepared and just not doing the
job that they're supposed to be doing
um it they they need respect they should
have respect because you're in charge of
uh some usually something larger even if
it's a smaller production you know you
still got some money on the line
um
but they it you've got you're you're the
person in the position of
a pile of money
you have a Target that you're aiming for
at the end of it with some sort of
story or something
um
you have to dictate things to all these
other departments and if they don't have
your respect they are not going to be
delivering their best work more than
likely because if they don't like you if
they're if they don't
respect you or don't want to be there
they're going to probably just try to
they're just trying to power through the
day that's a really bad that you don't
want your team members in that position
um and I don't think that that if you
find yourself in that position it's this
is not necessarily because you have
experience or not that's not usually
doesn't have
anything to do with it it's usually it
has to do with
your preparation uh
directors who are not prepared
really lose the respect of their crew
very quickly because the worst possible
thing you can do on set as a director is
not know what you want to sit there
the clock is ticking and you're going
should we put we should put the camera
so if we put the camera up here
and then
ah it makes everyone crazy and they're
going to start rolling their eyes and
being very frustrated with you and
they're gonna start in second guessing
your decisions and things like that
coming into your location beforehand and
knowing they're going to enter through
this door and they're going to go out to
that door and I I want to just move the
camera this way you have to know every
little detail but having an idea of what
you want
um
it's super important and you could do
that with that experience
and if you don't know how to to even
shoot a scene you can get your DP to
help you with that as long as you know
what you want that comes from
preparation
um
even having like an idea of say for
example a wardrobe you know you want I
want it to look like this guy has been
up all night
that can be enough of a description for
your wardrobe person at least now they
know what you want okay so he's he slept
in his clothes okay good
and so a little bit of wrinkles in yeah
yeah you know that kind of thing if you
came in and you're like
I don't know he's just wearing like
clothes like normal
but that's maddening to work for You're
Gonna Lose the respect of everybody
really quickly so it's absolutely vital
to have respect but it's not something
that you will get just automatically
um
but you can get it by make sure you're
doing the work so shot listing and
storyboarding yep shot listing
storyboarding is very helpful uh you
don't have to storyboard necessarily
there's a lot of schools of thought on
that it depends on the style that you're
going for sometimes uh
you don't have time you know so like
there's a show I've been working on
where we're running so fast there's not
time for storyboards there's not even
time for a shot list but at least
um knowing
the basics even like I'm prepared as
much as I can be in the moment I know
that these two characters are coming in
and this is their objective and we have
to get them back out and we have to do
it in five minutes or less so at least
having some goal posts to hit at a
minimum is helpful the more you know the
better it is and the easier it is for
your team to work with you
what's your image of a Bad director
Badger you know I've seen a lot of bad
directors I can picture them in my mind
that you know the first believe it or
not the first sign I see of a Bad
director is someone who doesn't know how
to talk to an actor
I I think think about
what it takes to be a director
you can do it
the best place for a director to be is
like television you can go into a
television and uh the DP already is set
to look
the this
the writers wrote everything for you
the actors know their characters and uh
you don't really have to do anything but
the the the DP is probably going to be
able to set it up and while we normally
shoot it when the guy goes over here and
he cooks dinner there this is normally
how we shoot the scene okay great the
actors are still going to know what you
want
so if you don't know how to talk to them
and they're and they're feeling alone
and vulnerable that that's that's a
problem
um
and that is the one job
that no one can really help you with
someone else can light it someone else
can get all the costumes ready in the
stunts and stuff but
someone's got to talk to the actors
someone's going to give them emotions
and and help
pull moments out of them especially if
they've shut down who else is going to
do that for you you it's up to you so
um
there's no more important job than that
I think
how do you gut check yourself
to know hey am I moving into Bad
director mode
yeah you know
if I feel like
I'm in danger of being a bad director
I'm just I'm waiting for all the commas
to appear below the video like you are a
bad director
if I feel like I'm I'm edging into that
territory it always comes down to my
prep
if I find myself
department heads are asking me
so um what do you want for the color of
the walls and I haven't thought about
that yet
um
I know that
especially if we're approaching the
shoot I know that there's a problem and
especially if there are gaps like
what I've noticed is is what I was
called bad directing
it's really easy to focus just on one
aspect of the shoot like
oh it's going to be in
place all lit with Christmas lights and
and it's going to be shot on a Steadicam
and we're going to spin in a circle cool
so what are the actors doing
oh we'll figure that out when we get
there uh you haven't really thought
about that department too much
um
that's uh that's that's usually my gut
going alarm Bells alarm Bells you know
you you need to take a minute and sit
and think about that this comes back to
a big thing I think we all struggle with
which is resistance
uh your gut you inside know what you
need to do to be successful but
sometimes for whatever reason Boop it
comes up where you you just don't want
to
um you'll resist sitting down and
writing out your shot list because it
feels a lot like work
so I know that if I if there are there's
usually that thing and sometimes it's
shotless and I like doing shot lists
that's what's so crazy but if I feel
like I haven't done it or see that I
haven't done it and my alarm bells are
going off inside I'm definitely leaning
into bad territory and I feel it on set
because there's always this little sense
of inner Panic that comes up where
um
I don't know what I'm what I'm doing
here
it's it is a really uncomfortable bad
spot to be in when it happens uh because
it's already hard enough on set it's
already
and you know where else it comes up is
where I think that I don't need to think
about it
whenever I approach a situation where oh
it's just another breakup scene
we shot a bunch of these it's just gonna
be in the ice cream shop the two things
they're going to leave
and I don't put the work in because I
don't feel like I really need to that's
usually when things really go south too
oh the ice cream shop is closed and they
and the actor is allergic to Dairy
oh
um oh well I don't know what to do you
know that because that kind of thing
will happen it just happens all the time
so
which is why you prepare which is why
you do the work ahead of time you're
preparing for Murphy because Murphy will
show up he will
make no mistake about it that's why you
prepare because everything is going to
go sideways on you at some point it just
will so
yeah
you've brought up persistence a lot are
you a fan of the war of Art
yes the war yes because that's how it
starts right it talks about resistance
that that really rung my bell when he
talked about that like because you the
thing about resistance that's so
Sinister is that no one else can tell
you we can we're really good at making
ourselves look busy
even to our partners or on social media
but we know if we're resisting we're the
only ones who know generally you know if
you're supposed if you know that you
have that screenplay that you're
supposed to be writing and you just
aren't
no one's your partner may be looking
you'd be oh he works on it every day but
is he though am I though you know we We
Only We Know It And so it's uh yeah it
and it can look like all sorts of things
it can look like
it can look like uh
exercise
uh every time I sit down to write that
oh I just need to go for a walk oh guess
what you're not doing while you're
walking you're not writing it could look
like
I think he even says in the book it
could be sex could be a resistance thing
you know you just suddenly I'm really
horny
um
yeah for every person is different
social media is probably the biggest
resistance uh blocker which is you know
and social media is a killer for art
it's killer it doesn't you know favors
whatsoever it's
there really isn't any purpose to it
especially for artists like what are you
doing if like what do we really need it
for
you know how is it actually helping your
career we like to we like to kid
ourselves and tell us that oh well
people need to know that I'm busy
do they though like how many jobs have
we legitimately gotten from Facebook
I mean unless you're in part of a
Facebook group that
posts a job and you happen to be one of
the first five that do it and they're
looking for an art Department person
I I can't think of it I people will
message me and say it looks like you're
busy but I've never landed a job from
one of those social media platforms it's
all about the grand advertisement to
show people that
you're more important than you are
that's usually the point of social media
is
yeah
not the point of everything
to advertise to the world that you're
more successful more good looking more
that your life is so great and perfect
probably isn't that what we do as humans
yeah we just want to fool everyone into
thinking that we're something
yeah
for any new filmmakers watching can you
take us through the process of making a
film all the way from getting financing
to getting cast attached below the line
people working all yeah
if we're talking about making a specif
like a movie specifically that's what
you mean like actually yeah so
um the general process of making the
movie is you know of course it starts
with a script got to get a script from
somewhere
um
hopefully fine financing in some way
shape or form but whether that's an
investor or credit cards or something
usually at that point then you find
casting then it becomes you know
putting your crew together
probably starting with someone like a
cinematographer
deciding to look the props you move into
production
you're doing that whole scene and then
then it's post on the end of it that's
the general building blocks which are
probably fairly obvious
the trick is how do you do it how do you
if you're if you've never done it like
how do you even
move that ball down the field at all
um
that's usually the big question how do I
make a movie how do you get
on the world do you do it
I've done three features to this point
and each one of them came about in
different ways
the first one so
actually the first one I ever tried to
make I I did everything you were
supposed to do I read all the books I
read Rebel Without a crew I did I read
you know all the books that all the
filmmakers read about independent film
and whatever
I wrote a script my mom told me it was
really great
and
all my friends told me how great it was
I found an investor a guy who helped me
with a business plan but he was only
willing to invest
in the trailer
he didn't have enough money to actually
fund the whole film but he knew business
cool that's something I lack
so we wrote it we did a killer trailer
we set out to raise money
everybody told me you have never made a
feature so how and I was trying to raise
like a million bucks I think I was sorry
budget every investor said this is a
high-risk investment
and you've never made a movie so how am
I
how do I know I'm ever going to see it
again and how do I know you know what
you're doing I heard that over and over
and over again for several years before
I finally gave up it was so demoralizing
because actually the trailer we made was
good we thought for sure people would be
into it didn't work didn't work at all
it was not what the books told me that
would happen it was not
it was very frustrating so here I am
Back Square One
got this cool movie trailer yay
for a film that doesn't exist okay
so I had to go back to the drawing board
and go all right so then how do I make a
movie how do I get this thing made so I
I wrote a different script
and I wrote this script
based on things that I knew I had access
to so
I shoot a lot of underwater stuff all
right I can I can maybe add some of that
I wouldn't recommend that and it's an
independent feature film I did it anyway
um wrote this little murder mystery
thing
I set out to raise forty thousand
dollars forty thousand you know I was
thinking before I thought to myself
I've shot a lot on my camera you know
I've shot I have a lot of experience
behind the camera I had tried to teach
myself as much as I could about
filmmaking I'd worked with another
director a whole bunch and he showed me
how 5c stands and a couple of flags and
a little light kit can really do a lot
for you so I'm like and I learned a lot
from him he taught me all this great
stuff so I bought I literally bought
five C stands handful of flags had a
light kit
that's it that's all I had
doorway Dolly little bit of track and
okay I can I can make a movie with just
these few elements I'll cast my friends
as the actors
I'm gonna raise 40 Grand
I couldn't raise 40 Grand I raised 12.
and you know all the people that threw
in was fantastic they were all good
friends of mine but that still left me
in this place of like man how am I
supposed to pull this off without
anything
I decided Well I'm gonna take that money
and use it for catering
and for the couple of rentals that I
need and I'm gonna do it anyway
so I sat out and shot for
five straight weeks
um I shot it during this is this is
really helpful
the people I cast
the first one was an actor who was in
acting school he was on his Christmas
break for a month so he was actually
home for a month that I could grab him
for
that was very helpful
um I did not break the shoot up into
tiny pieces like a lot of people do
because that gets really dangerous
because your actors you know someone's
gonna get married that someone's going
to get a haircut
you know trying to coordinate people for
months and months and months on end it's
increasingly difficult to do
so I tried to shoot it all in one block
just to get it knocked out and get it
out of the way
so
um over at Christmas time was a great
time work is slow gear is available
sometimes Crews available that made
everything exponentially easier
um
I paid everybody with food
had a friend do the K we we came up with
this little and by the way everything we
had a crew of five
every all the lighting fit in my SUV and
the I had this little tupperware
container
with um you know napkins forks and
knives salt and pepper things like that
that the K this friend of mine was kind
of helping us cater and she would fill
that up and had all the crafty in it I
could just pull it out and wheel it it
didn't set and she would bring like a
casserole or something every morning it
was a great little system she wasn't
there all day but it was something so
that the crew was taken care of and uh I
planned like I've never planned before
like I I went and looked at each
location I measured each room to make
sure that the because I wanted to know
if I want to do a doorway Dolly shot
through this little doorway is it even
wide enough for me to do that so I
measured it to make sure it was right
and then pre-planned out where all my
shots would be so that I could be a
military operation in every single
location because I did not have the
money to to be able to do extra reshoots
and things like that so I had this giant
three ring binder like this that with
every little detail at every scene which
scene came before which scene came after
so that I could meet because I didn't
have a scripty I had myself I was DP I
had three film students and I had a art
Department person and a stunt
coordinator like those were that was it
that's all I had
so I needed to be able to create a
system to where I could do it all myself
um and I did it I pulled it off
now I will say it was one of the most
exhausting experiences of my life
um it I actually put myself in the
hospital from exhaustion I've ended up
passing out in the shower
um but I did it I got it done and
sometimes making your first feature will
take that to you'll have you may
hopefully not you may have to push
yourself further than you ever thought
possible but if you want it this might
be what you have to do push yourself so
much further than you thought and it
wasn't like I had this great day job gig
where I could afford to take all this
time off I couldn't I was living on
credit cards and I had to push and push
and push now here's the thing
foreign
that film
it's you can watch it if you want
it's a 12 000 movie it's never gonna be
it it's a talk it looks like a n sounds
like a twelve thousand dollar movie and
it's not anything great you can it's on
Amazon it's called the human Trace you
can watch it if you want
watch it
only to inspire you to make something
better
um I would also tell you at the same
time go watch Christopher Nolan's
following it was shot for like six grand
so
but because Christopher Nolan made
following he got to make Memento right
sometimes it takes that first one to get
you out the door and if no one is giving
you a shot you're just gonna have to
figure out how to give it to yourself
that's what I had to do and it took
everything I had to make it happen but I
will tell you that after you know 25
years later it is my most proudest
accomplishment because I did it on my
own and I did it and I made it happen
you won a couple awards did okay it was
never sold for a lot of money it didn't
do
you know you're we're all hoping we're
all hoping that when we do it that
that's going to be the thing that opens
the door don't count on that it probably
won't hey if it happens for you that's
fantastic but
be careful what how you pin your hopes
on on that one project and I learned
that in the biggest way on film number
two
so so film number one was done
the true Indie filmmaker way which was
she Blood Sweat and Tears doing
everything yourself you know
all of that
um
even to the point we recorded like all
the underwater Sounds by taking a
microphone and putting a condom around
it and dipping it in a swimming pool and
then making underwater sounds and did
all the sound design like that like it
was it was interesting safe recording
that that's right no one got pregnant
uh
uh so that's one way that you can do it
and I will say that the process of that
now the film itself did not open doors
however
from that point forward I could tell
people that I made a movie
they're not going to watch this movie
that doesn't matter I could tell people
that I made the movie that
did help when it came to the second one
because I was able to tell people I've
done this before I've been through this
Mill before I know how to make a
two-hour story and make it hold together
second film was done
was paid for by a large organization
that they wanted to dramatize a book
so this is an interesting now this is
another way you can make films happen
and I've seen people do this because
they will take a story and wrap it
around a Cause
if you can attach your story
to say a book like in the case of this
it was a book they wanted to dramatize
or you can come up with a cause say I
don't know voting rights or
ending childhood hunger or something
right there are organizations that
really
you know they're champions of this and
massive organizations that are around it
fight this kind of thing and you can get
them to partner with you
you will also have a built-in audience
it's a great way to get a film going if
if your film has some sort of bent like
that it'll give you a platform access to
investors and things like that cool
that's fantastic it also it feels good
when you get out of bed in the morning
because you're making a film that's
actually
doing good like this so my next film was
like that what that means is that means
two things
I'm working for a client that's
different than your own little film
this is going to be more like what it
was like working in a studio and I'm
also making a film based on pre-existing
materials so I'm adapting a book
for a client so that means that I have
to work with a committee of people who
are dictating the story and they're
telling me
things they want in it certain agendas
that they have that is a
that is what you will run into when you
do a film for an organization this is
it's not necessarily A Bad Thing it can
be a very collaborative feeling in this
case it was a very positive creative
experience
uh the the executive producer and myself
are very good friends to this day we're
still working together
um we made this film it's called The
Record Keeper it it was a wonderful
experience to make it's a steampunk
sci-fi thriller about angels and all
that it was super super fun
but
the organization decided at the end of
it not to release it and it's a whole
long sort of story as to why but
this taught me lesson number two which
is
when you tie your hopes
to what your project can do or will do
it's a dangerous place to be it's it's
some people refer to that as living in
the future you are
I I wish I could remember which sports
team this was but I know there's a
famous story about a football team that
was
it was playing this game and this one
team thought they had won it and I think
there was a interception or a tackle or
something and
team a Ah that's it we won the game and
the fans started flooding the the
stadium and things like that but the
play wasn't over
and the other team somehow grabbed the
ball picked up and run it to the other
end zone
and it was discovered somehow in this
crazy celebration that they actually
lost
viewers may remember what this story is
I can't quite remember what it is off
the top of my head but that this is
actually something to happen this is an
example of a team that got so focused on
the future
of winning X going to film festival
winning winning Sundance that they
completely lost sight of where they
actually were and that was a very
devastating lesson for me to learn which
was we made this film we were winning
Awards people were so excited we were on
set you could feel the Magic in the air
as we were creating and we're working
with actors the story was really cool
we felt like we were on this launching
pad
and all of a sudden we go launching into
the stratosphere and the organization
says no
and I took a tumble off of that into a
very dark place to the point where I
almost gave up making films it was so
hard because you we worked so hard to
get through you to break through right
you're just trying every step of the way
to write the screenplays to work with
the actors and then finally someone
gives you a shot and then they bam they
shut the door on your face it felt like
well then what's the point
you know it just it I seriously thought
about my wife and I talked at length
about maybe we should just go teach
English
in Korea or something and just give up
uh
it was because I was pinning my hopes on
what it I thought it was going to do
up here uh and I lost sight of where the
reality of where it actually was
realizing this is a very real
possibility the signs were there going
along that this could happen but I just
didn't want to see it I just believed
that it would do better than that
so
I recovered from that whole experience
which took some time took a lot of
licking of the wounds and
eventually down the line I got back on
my feet
I ended up at this
for a time I worked I did I ended up
getting a job it was a way that I I got
to LA and this is something very
interesting because I feel like the
second film that I did if I had lived in
La things would have turned out
differently because my friend's Circle
would have been different well I was
living in another city
and the people that I was surrounded by
and people making movies the artists
involved
were just from that City
if I had been in La making this with LA
people I think other it would have been
higher exposure I think the results
would have been different that's as a
side note
so after all this went down it was also
financially devastating so I had to find
a way to get to La after all of this
after this huge wound and and all right
now I need I need to get down there and
try to figure out a way to make this
happen
so I ended up taking a full-time job
which was very that you know after going
whoop I want to be I want to be famous
ah
work a full-time job at a job I hate
I'm the world's worst person right so
boom so I'm in this full-time job but
but while I was in this job
first of all I gave myself a time limit
I'm not I'm only going to be here for a
year this is just to get me to La so I I
did that and while I was in the job
I thought okay I need to get film number
three off the ground I can't let this
second experience be the death of me I
can't let that be the defining moment of
my life
so I went to the Austin film festival
and I met Dwayne Worrell there and we
connected and I followed up with him
this is the traditional way how movies
are supposed to be made right so
we get back to LA we became Fast Friends
he sends me the script I couldn't put it
down I love the script so much I asked
him if it was okay
if I pitched it around
he said yes I went to another Film
Festival connected with these other
group of producers came back they said
to them they said that's great that's a
green line now this is the traditional
way of how you want it to happen in
Hollywood right so these are three
different possible ways of how films get
made is any of them right or wrong
absolutely not
um
but it's just a way of demonstrating and
how this actually happens
um
the third way I will say is has been the
most interesting because I'm working for
a production house who's done multiple
films there's a great comfort in that
because they have had things distributed
way more than I have they have done they
they understand the ins and outs of the
other side of the business that I'm not
as familiar with
um
that's fantastic there's also a great
because I'm in La I have a great network
of filmmakers
to choose from to help me make this
thing that's also a huge asset it's
given us access to film festivals
um
that I didn't have before so there's
enormous value in going after a film
like that in that way now
the film is about to release at the time
of this recording so we will see how
this particular process goes but um
you know I
so how is a film made it's it's in any
way that you possibly can it's
you you
I had to put myself in the hospital make
the first one I had to take a job I
hated for the Third
and all of them were worth it
because once you're there and you're
doing it it is the the dream that we've
all striven for
it's real It's Magic it's it's fantastic
it's the best job in the world